Yeah,
oh,
you dirty bitches with live.
This is a woman playing the background.
It's a band called honey honey and it's
the song's called the angel of death.
I'm in love with this chase voice.
I heard this like an hour ago.
Somebody posted on my message board and
then I just listened to it and I've
listened to like 10 times such as such a
pitch.
I'm such a bitch for like a hot girls
voice,
a girl with a beautiful voice man.
There's like a weird harmony that it
connects to in inside yourselves.
You know?
I don't think I bet women to understand
it.
You know?
I don't know.
I don't even know.
I don't even think this chick knows what
she's doing.
She knows how to do it though,
but the,
the impact that it has on the male
standing,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the link for the flashlight
and into her in the codename Rogan,
you'll get 15 percent off.
Number one sex toy from her.
There's no other way to say that.
I got to come up with a better way,
Brian.
I got to come up with something creative
that have been there.
Yeah.
They've been saying they'll help you get
you one.
Do you want one?
I'm missing out on life otherwise.
So if you want one dude,
I got one for you.
I,
they just sent me a big buck
and I brought one for studio flashlight
and it lasted less than 24 hours.
I brought it here and I was just going
to use it.
Just show it you just in case people ask
about flashlight because everyone always
asks about what,
what's,
Hey,
what's this?
And so I had it for less than 24 hours
and was like,
dude,
please can I have one sea herring?
Uh,
so.
So see stole your flashlight.
I gave it to him,
gave it to him.
He's fucking right now.
Probably.
Yeah,
I gave him the black
model.
One,
two.
Nice.
Well look man,
it works.
Solid product.
We wouldn't doors it less.
It was good.
It's a funny thing to get behind.
You know,
people,
people find it very offensive and
pathetic and juvenile.
And I'm not sure,
but I like it.
I liked the fact that people are
bothered by it and it's so stupid.
It just highlights how fucking
ridiculous we are.
Completely ridiculous that we would care
at all about pleasure.
You know,
that we care at all about like a device.
It's really good at extracting sperm.
That's all it is.
You know,
what's your fucking problem?
People were also brought to you by
[inaudible] Dot Com,
o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
the cognitive enhancement supplement.
I didn't take mine today.
I hope I don't sound stupid.
Got Some right here.
If you want to hook a brother up,
I would say a Nigga,
but I'm not that confident.
Beautiful.
Um,
if you go to on it.com,
o n n I,
t,
all of this will be explained.
What it is is essentially nutrients for
your mind.
It's not gonna make you a genius if
you're a retard,
but it's going to enhance the way your
brain works,
going to give you.
It gives you like a feeling of mental
clarity and energy.
Um,
there's a lot of people that don't
understand.
Nootropics are,
they don't know what new nootropics are.
I suggested you as Google.
It's an Oh,
new tropics,
and it's all about vitamins and
nutrients that help your brain function
at a good level.
And um,
you know,
there's plenty of studies that had been
done on this and you should research it
before you buy any of this stuff.
Also,
I want to say that if you,
if you see on its products and you want
to try it,
you're not sure if it's gonna work for
you.
You don't know,
try it.
The first 30 pills are 100 percent money
back guarantee.
If you don't like it,
we want to make it as easy as possible
for you so you even have to send the
stuff back.
If you try it and you don't feel like it
has any effect on you,
then send,
send the pills back or d or excuse me,
don't even send the pills back.
You don't have to do shit.
You just get your money back.
Uh,
used to be with as many as people
ordered.
But unfortunately a bunch of people
decided to just buy a bunch of it.
Get all their money back and then sell
it on Ebay.
That old story.
It's not even a story.
It's a fable.
It's a true story and it's their story
though.
I've sounded it so many times.
That's the problem,
but it is always ultimately true.
It's a fairytale.
You think so now it's fairy because
patrols,
if I've said it too many times,
it's become.
It's become like not real anymore.
Yeah,
you're right.
It does.
It changes a little bit every time.
Like you know.
Well they did.
They bought a bunch of them.
They bought like nine owners and they
sold them on Ebay.
That's the story.
That's all I know though.
Dude.
I don't know.
Next weekend is going to be Amazon
marketplace too.
I didn't make this up,
man.
Don't be an asshole trying to do a
little commercial here.
You're going to help him.
Brian.
We're also a.
We make a shroom tech sport,
which is a quarter step mushrooms,
a supplement.
It's got beat 12 in it too.
It's great for any,
any really,
really hard workout people if you're in
the crossfit or anything crazy like
that.
It's a.
it's a great endurance enhancement
supplement,
really helps you push into points where
you would ordinarily be fatigued.
You know,
I don't.
I wouldn't suggest any of this if you're
not someone who works out though.
There's also shroom,
tech,
immune,
all this stuff,
if you're fascinated by it,
a far better description than I could
ever give is on [inaudible] dot com.
That's o n n I,
t and M.
There's also a,
an enhanced science of Alpha brain where
we've updated due to some criticisms
updated.
We hired a science advisor and updated
the way everything is described and
everyone's trying to be as above board
and cooled this as possible.
So that's what it is.
If you're fascinated by nootropics,
go to [inaudible] dot com.
O n n I t enter in code named Rogan.
You get 10 percent off,
not just the first order either.
Now it's as many orders as you want.
We fixed that shit.
Alright.
Powerful.
Daniella boat.
At least in the house.
You're like a 12 year old DJ.
That's like the kind of like sound
effects.
I would be really interesting.
I was a Dj and I was 12.
Yeah.
Or it sounds like a sports broadcast,
you know,
like this week.
Yeah.
A lot of those sports guys are hard to
handle.
Intense.
Yeah.
With this special breed of guys that
like shit on athletes,
you know,
there's like some of them that are just
sports broadcasters,
but some of those dudes like they do.
Um,
and then the like he's a bomb.
He's always been a bomb.
He'll never get off the bench and you're
like,
whoa.
Like you're talking about like a
professional athlete.
Their son,
you better settle the fuck down man.
You're getting a little crazy with your
insults,
their fat guy in front of a microphone.
How dare you,
you know,
I like that insult shit.
Right?
Daniella Bolelli my friend or shut up.
Exactly.
So brother,
you are a scholar of religious history,
right?
I mean you are essentially.
Why not?
Yeah,
I mean that's the best way to describe
it.
You are actually a professor on it.
Yup.
How do you think that it is that we live
in 2012 and we have this incredible
depth of religion.
It's still controlling our lives.
How is it possible that something that
seemed so like it,
it seems so if you were rationally
looking at it,
you would go,
okay,
maybe there's some truth behind any of
this.
Maybe,
maybe,
maybe there's some truth behind the
origins of the creation of the universe,
but clearly this shit has been written
by people and we're going to base our
lives on this.
This is fucking bananas.
People when they say base our lives,
most people will say they do,
but then of course when it's convenient,
when it's not,
it's like,
let's conveniently forget a couple of
passages.
Like there's um,
but aren't those the safest ones?
The ones that stick to the code,
those are the most danger.
The ones that want to throw rocks at
you,
like dancing a Christian girl who slept
around every now and then.
You know what I mean?
That's like way better.
I've seen someone who completely stick
to the code.
Yeah.
No,
but I mean several of the sinks are
because they boiled it down to wheat or
now the type of questions that no one
has an answer to and sort of fact these,
unless you know,
people always say,
oh,
it's good already in decades we go for
science and reason and we need to be
irrational and don't get me wrong.
Give me a reason why he's a great tool,
but if it doesn't give you answers to
things that scare the hell out of
people,
people are going to want some answers.
Whether they are bullshit dancers or
not,
doesn't matter.
It's like,
give me some answer because otherwise
it's just damn scary.
His religion than a tool to allow people
to psychologically adapt to the next
stage of evolution.
Like,
like something like a placeholder.
Yeah,
I mean I think it's what people need to
deal with.
The fact that I can't deal with
uncertainty.
Is it possible at all that any of it is
based on reality?
I mean know that so it sounds
ridiculous,
but so does the universe itself,
like the universe itself is pretty
ridiculous.
The Big Bang is pretty ridiculous.
I don't claim to know shit,
so who knows what's up there.
I,
I don't believe or disbelieve,
you know,
my
attitude is there's what I've
experienced and there's every single
house.
Yeah.
What I've experienced,
I kind of know.
And every single males who the hell
knows,
you know,
I mean it pissed me off when people
assume that stuff,
that they themselves as an Evan
expedience somewhere that's the ultimate
truth and everybody needs to believe
that.
It's like,
what the hell?
Why?
How nuts would it be if you died and you
really were at a date in the cloud,
how psychedelic would that be if you
really did have a dude,
St Peter who's like the FBI who's just
been following your license,
you're a baby and he's like going over
day,
why'd you do this and why'd you do that?
Like fucking really.
That would really,
that would wearing a mom and she.
Can you imagine,
what does that really stand for
something though?
I mean,
I wonder if that ideal that this ideal
of,
you know,
having to live like a Karma free life
and having to like have done only good
things only be pure and then you get to
um,
a moment.
I mean,
is that what they're,
are they envisioning a moment of
ultimate enlightenment?
When you're framing what is the idea of,
you know,
of,
of the heaven,
like where's it coming from?
Is it coming from the need for the next
level?
We're the,
the possibility.
What would be the best possible
scenario?
The best possible scenarios.
All loved ones would be in the clouds
forever and ever.
But really,
how fucking long would that last before
you were bored as fuck.
But you imagine if that's heaven,
you're just hanging out in the clouds.
You can't drive anywhere.
You can't go to the movies.
Everybody's up together and having,
what the fuck is that?
That's ridiculous.
No flashlights were.
We all have wings now,
so we just fly around up here.
You know,
what do we do after a while?
You get bored.
Where are you getting your food?
You're in the clouds,
you know,
you eating fucking cloud fish.
What are you doing?
Where are you getting your food?
This is ridiculous.
We don't need food anymore.
Oh my God.
What is there to live for?
That would be my question.
Are their flashlights in Africa?
Can you fucking have it?
How about that?
How about that question?
You know,
you fucking heaven.
If there was heaven,
would you be allowed to?
So what if it was just like a smoker?
Replace.
The whole thing was just smoke here.
You know,
like you're like,
you're not allowed to smoke,
you know,
all the time.
So like you can have full relationships
and get girls pregnant.
You can still get a driver's license,
but everything's just really smokey.
Yeah,
that sounds.
That makes sense.
But fucking talks because you're in
heaven.
It's all cloudy clouds.
So it's like real life book Seattle,
like maybe hit Seattle.
Seattle.
Exactly sucked.
I'm definitely going to vegas.
Oh Wow.
Vegas.
Vegas is some sort of purgatory.
No,
that's definitely.
Oh,
it's like in their logo.
State motto.
Hi.
I think it is.
Well,
you know what?
There's about the
human behavior man,
when you get them in that frying pan
frying pan.
That is Las Vegas,
you know,
I hate it now.
I just don't even want to go there.
I just went two days ago and Jesus just
that drive there.
I was like,
fuck,
I forgot how bad it is,
but it's fun to.
As it is,
it's the best place to go see fights.
It's like no other place.
Like it's going to the best club,
like a bar one night and then you're
hanging out there for a couple of days.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a weird town.
I like Vegas.
There's a lot of things I like about.
There's plenty of cool people in Vegas,
you know?
It's just the reality is when you get
people and you just let them go free
like that.
Do you give them 24 hour free rein,
go drink and you just wind up doing
ridiculous shit.
That's what I need though because you
see these people that are doing or why
do we know this sheets and you know that
they are the ones who are at 9:00
AM at tie.
Then I'm like,
this is the current,
Florida's lave is the.
I know it must be a fucking grind and
try to go back to work after a weekend
of that,
but people who lived there,
man,
they must get an extraordinary view of
humanity.
They have like,
they would be like great psychologists.
People live in Vegas.
They probably understand a lot about
people.
You know,
if you work at a casino,
say if feel like some dude,
you could be like a guy who's like a
real crafty dude who lives in vegas,
could really describe humanity in a very
unusual level.
Probably know any of the show and just
see them at their real estate.
Just the idea that you would get people
and allow them to drink through all
hours of the night thinking,
drink whenever they want.
Like nobody ever tells you to stop
drinking.
It's so ridiculous that just drinks it,
that you need a drink.
Like why are you can still drink.
This is crazy.
It's just that alone is nuts.
You know,
we're just a note.
No one's used to that shit.
So that's.
So that's a weird thing.
Alcohol removes inhibition and then you
have.
So it's like just that alone is what
makes Vegas fucking completely insane.
I mean,
you wanted freedom.
Here you go.
You got it.
Let's see how it goes.
That is.
Dan was the first time that I actually
was anywhere rather than on the street.
I was like,
Whoa,
there are actually people living here.
It is.
This weird filter was just an adult.
He's not on there.
So I'd love it though.
I love the fact that there's is a place
like that.
I love the fact that there's a place
where people can gamble.
I don't even gamble,
but I love that you could just go gamble
at 3:00
in the morning.
I don't do it,
but if I was into it,
I would love the fact that I could just
do that.
You know?
I just,
I hate the fact that you can't,
you know,
you have to go somewhere for something
like that.
You know that we restrict that sort of
behavior everywhere else that's big
enough that our lead Gen is one other
thing that pissed me off the most
because I mean people being religious,
I have nothing against it.
If it,
if it helps you being nicer to your
neighbors or whatever.
Good for you.
The stamina piece me off to no end is
when they want to impose their own
morality on you and so the victim of
this crime slow,
you know,
no gambling,
no show,
no drugs,
no.
But is there a positive message in
trying to control some vices?
I mean,
is there a.
is there anything that you could say as
far as like social engineering,
like man,
if you wanted to have a really safe
environment,
maybe what'd you make?
Prostitution illegal.
Would you make drugs illegal?
Would you try to suppress it or would
you do.
Do you think that the safer thing would
be to just decriminalize it and let
people figure it out for themselves?
Mediamath regulation.
I'm kind of like the way that the dam or
something.
Yeah,
exactly.
Where do you have some safety standards
is good for everybody involved.
You limit the damage that people can do
to themselves and to others that,
hey,
it's your choice.
Which our life.
Yeah,
that's weird thing,
man,
isn't it?
It's a weird thing,
but just the idea that you can control
what other people do,
but only to a certain extent.
Like we don't say that we can control
porn yet.
Although there was a thing about Newt
Gingrich and Mitt Romney and Rick
Santorum,
all of them are going to go after porn.
Was that who it was?
It was that.
It was at least two of those characters
we're going to go after porn I think was
gingrich and Santorum.
I don't think about.
Not that it makes much difference
because those guys are,
you know,
different shades of gray.
But man,
it's so weird the now anyone on or could
devote for Santorum scare the shit out
of me.
A lot of people are voting for him.
They love this guy.
What do you think they're connecting to?
I mean,
you as a person who,
he's obviously the message,
uh,
quite a bit of it is that is religious.
I mean that kind of stuff you'd boys
down to somebody will give you the image
of what you would want to have.
We are,
we promote all the good guys will,
uh,
be rewarded old.
The bad guys will be pioneers.
We stand for morality,
we squash anything else.
And the thing that makes some of these
people feel good is we'll squash every
one else who doesn't agree with living
life the way we do so we can impose our
happy dog mountain of anyone else
because that ultimately is the kind of
shit that he stands for.
And it's a,
people like it.
I mean,
he's not just 30 Joanie.
If you look even outside of early John
People voted for a color,
you know,
it's not,
it wasn't just purely taking power.
People like Nazism,
people like the hardcore form of
communism,
people like,
they like certainties.
They like somebody with least puts up a
strong face and is like a stand for all
of this volume of solid,
clean know that shit.
Then simplify life.
And that's scary to me.
It's really scary.
Yeah.
Big Time because uh,
I mean it's not real.
It's based on a,
it's based on numbers.
Yeah.
And he must have a belief.
You must have a belief.
I mean,
there's no way he could be talking this
much if he doesn't have a belief,
but anybody who believes something that
they can't really prove and believed it
to a point where they're willing to base
their lives on it like that.
And,
and you want
just run the biggest nuclear arsenal in
the world.
Really?
Look what,
look what you're banking on.
Look,
look what liquid corner you're in.
You're in the corner of fire and
brimstone for real.
Yep.
You're in the corner of gays.
Shouldn't be allowed to get married.
And like,
what?
What are you doing in 2012?
Why do you want to give a fuck about
what gay guys are doing?
Your Weirdo.
What kind of Weirdo gives a fuck about
what some gay guys are doing?
Like,
oh,
we have to stop that.
Birth control is bad.
Yeah.
Such fucking crazy.
It's like he's.
He's like pulling us back in the 1960
[inaudible] his birth controls.
Awesome.
Did you can shoot loads in a checks and
I don't get pregnant.
You stupid.
Fuck
dummy.
You fucking dummy.
Have you ever tried the female condom on
a girl?
Who was that?
Like a dental dam?
Yeah,
it's like a dental dam,
but like you could just come as much as
you want into her.
Like it's amazing but you have to change
it because it's like a vagina diaper
because it gets really full.
So that team that you just gave us the
bus draw girl.
Nobody was killed my son.
Seriously?
Yeah.
Who's going to be all excited like my
vagina diaper.
It is.
Guys will still fuck you if you have a
diaper.
We don't care.
We can get over that real quick.
You know,
for a woman that would be a w.
probably a a deal breaker.
You know,
he'd pull off a diaper,
bunch of goobers in a bag.
What if a girl got a diaper on,
had shit all over it and she was really
hot and you had a bunch of Napkins and
some hot towels and what?
You'd cleaned her ass and then her fuck.
Yeah.
Wouldn't even bother you.
Really hardly be like a little whatever.
Just got to deal with it.
Wipe her ass clean baby with big tits.
But for a girl,
for guy and like Shit's middle.
His Dick and his pubic hair,
she believed that's it.
It's all women know what it nearly as
much as we do.
I agree.
We'll clean ship.
We will clean your shitty ass
for real.
Right?
That's true.
I don't know why we're free.
We're free gear,
right?
Is that in the Bible?
Do you think that the Bible was
initially created just to try to keep
people in line?
You think it was created,
like look and these are some stories.
This is some lessons that we've learned
and then it just kinda like got out of
control.
Like I think it goes both ways.
There's some.
Sometimes you use it as a tool to
control people's behavior if you feel
that they are to fuck it up,
but also it's an internal thing.
I think he's not just a,
I know this is bullshit about.
I'm going to feed it to them just so I
keep it a crazy scene line.
I also think that sound,
the people themselves who started some
of these things feel needy.
They desperately need it to the point
where they will.
They are going to be the first one to
stick their own lives on it and that's I
guess the Santorum thing.
You know?
You want to leave that way.
I mean,
I think our knots,
but whatever.
It's your life.
You should be free to do whatever you
want when you want to impose it on
everyone else.
That's when you'll piss me off.
That's when it gets scary.
Yeah.
Which is bizarre to me.
Anybody who really absolutely believe
something that much is bizarre to me.
Yeah.
Like why do you believe in what you.
Where are you seeing this?
You really believe that book Zen.
What's going on?
Man?
This said,
that's how that seems crazy,
but you're banking it all in one book.
There's a lot of books,
man,
don't let a lot of shit has been
written,
you know,
and they're really.
The shit that's the weirdest is the
oldest.
You can't.
That's nonsense.
We need like a new behavior standard
guide for humans.
That's what we need instead of a Bible,
just a behavior standard guide so we can
all get through this world like this.
These are the rules that we agree to
instead have bestowed upon us by a
higher power.
Yeah,
you definitely shouldn't do most of this
shit.
The Bible says.
Tells you not to do.
Don't be killing anybody.
Don't fuck your neighbor's wife.
All that stuff.
That's all good.
Yeah,
you really should.
That's.
Those are good,
but we need some more of those and we
need like a comprehensive guide just
based on what we all know to be.
Right.
We all know,
I think this is the best time ever to do
something like that because even though
people were complaining that times are
tough and unemployment is bad,
and it certainly is economies and in
terrible position,
but still better than any time in human
history.
Right.
There's really been no better time as
far as like safety as far as like the
access to get food and medicine.
This if there's ever a time for us to
get our shit together.
Like on paper now,
is it like together as like a group of
humans instead of instead of bound by
some crazy words that were written first
in ancient Hebrew.
First of all,
they were.
They were told as an oral tradition,
Philip for thousand years first.
Yet it's not for seven.
Orlando,
Dr Kim.
Imagine what the fuck happens to a story
when you tell it for hundreds of years
before somebody figures out how to write
things.
Whoa.
That's nuts.
What do you think about those Dead Sea
Scrolls?
Do you know much about that?
I mean,
his artist sinks.
There's what are you fish?
Our scriptures of every religion are one
tiny part of what used to be out there,
and then people,
I mean you get to the kids as
Afghanistan,
literally,
they get to vote on which books are
sacred and come from God and which ones
are not that mean.
Can you believe that?
It's like somebody's seat around the
table.
What it's like today,
right now we pull out some book and go,
okay,
what do you think about it is these gods
are not.
Okay,
next let's talk about this one.
It was really that arbitrary.
I mean I nearly.
That's amazing.
How many books were like left out?
Are those available?
Who knows because a lot of these.
This is the end,
the Bible.
A lot of these was because he wasn't
like,
oh,
we decide this is God stuff and sold the
other stuff.
Well read it.
If you want to noise like we have to
burn it because it must be the Davao
son,
so it must be terrible and horrible and
we need to squash any possible other
alternative and soul that's burned them
old.
Wow.
And so when something goes pops up that
shows a different side to it that wasn't
made a part of the official Canon,
that it makes everybody feel like,
what the hell is going on like is so we
can base our life on this or can we or I
mean most people are going to ignore it
anyway because otherwise he masters with
categories.
But that's a good idea.
What a weird time.
Yeah,
I mean,
thinking about like the concept of
faith,
the stuff that's at the basie self,
uh,
Judaism,
Christianity,
Islam,
think about like the story that they
own,
the revere.
They all think he's a great idea.
You know,
God the shows up that say,
but um,
I really think you should kill your
song.
And they,
it's like,
well,
I don't want to kill my song,
but you know,
if it's God speaking wedding decades,
sorry,
bye.
Come on,
let's go.
He's about to kill him.
And then God sends an angel.
Say,
no,
wait,
just kidding.
Just testing your faith.
You know,
just checking.
You pass the test.
You did very well and now you're
rewarded for it.
You know,
last time I check when you hear these
embodied voices telling you,
you should kill people,
least thinning to that is not what
should make you the guy who everybody
looks up to.
One thing we want a great example of
faith.
You analyzing what a crazy story God
wants you to kill your baby.
Yeah,
what the fuck,
and you're gonna kill your baby for God
and that was the right thing to do and
God said he was just testing you.
Holy Shit.
That's a sign.
That good job you'll pass.
The test is that Old Testament.
The Old Testament is about as wonky as
it gets,
right?
Predictive,
but they said that the Dead Sea scrolls
were even wonkier.
Like you know,
there's,
there's a lot of dead sea scrolls stuff
that hasn't even been included.
That is the oldest written version,
right?
Jazz,
because it's not part of the official
cannon,
doesn't mean that it's all good stuff.
I think it's not like he's easy to fall
into the pattern of,
oh,
these evil bastards a manipulated the
seeings put on these horrible things in
the books.
And so every scene that got squashed
must be good.
No,
not really.
You know,
some of the stuff that got squashed,
it's probably even worse.
Who knows?
So I love the fact that the Dead Sea
Scrolls,
it was always linked to crazy shit.
People were always like,
it's always,
you have photos and mushrooms and it's
like every,
every wacky,
crazy story is linked to the Dead Sea
Scrolls,
you know,
even the fact they found them,
one of the coolest things is,
uh,
the science of putting together the
pieces because a lot of them were in
leather.
One of the ways they put together the
pieces,
what they did,
genetic testing on them to find out
which ones came from the same animal.
So they knew that it was a piece of
one's skin.
Incredible stuff,
man.
That's amazing.
Amazing stuff.
It was really incredible.
And they're still putting that fucking
thing together,
you know,
people are still trying to decipher it,
which broadly over the last 2000 years.
And they found that banter over those
things.
But you know,
500 years ago somebody would have looked
at it.
It's like,
hmm,
you know,
maybe I can start a fire with it or
something.
Yeah.
When you're starving and you have to
cook the book,
it,
you cook the book,
you know when you need something to
light a fire,
you're going to fuck that book.
Light it on fire.
We're going to die tonight.
You know,
bicycling.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
How much stuff was lost in the burning
of the library of Alexandria,
south of disordered.
I mean,
you're talking about thousands and
thousands of volumes.
It's pretty damn scary.
Yeah.
It's amazing to think that human beings
can be so fucking creative.
And then so destructive when people
don't understand is there was some sort
of incredibly advanced society that was,
that it created ancient Egypt.
I mean,
to this day it's a.
there's a bunch of puzzles when it comes
to the immense construction,
the,
the fact that how much just actual mass
was moved the size of some of these,
these,
uh,
old ballistics.
I mean,
it really is incredible society and they
knew a lot of things and all of it was
wiped out in a fire.
And I think it was two fires.
I think there was two different times
they were attacked.
Yeah.
I'm sort of like a man.
Well,
how much further would we be if we knew
all that Shit,
you know?
But it's the same kind of stuff that
happened even in other places because
when the Spaniards came over out here,
when they conquered the aztecs and the
Aztecs who are one of the indigenous
people that had big lied,
but our reason that books and written
language and the whole thing and the
Spanish approach was like,
well there's these look like in the
volleyball.
No,
while,
in decades.
It's gonna wait,
we can burn it.
Burn it though.
Hey,
that's nice.
But so if it wasn't a Bible,
they just burned it bazzy.
I mean,
it's like your guys that are not
curious,
don't see.
It must be devil worshipers and we
shouldn't burn evidence and you have
ever done because it's all crap.
Did they burn and Maya and stuff?
Yeah,
I mean basically anything that was in
mines inklings,
anybody you know there's still fine in
Mayan temples.
That fascinates me,
man.
They said that they might be as many as
a thousand unfound temples in South
America.
That's crazy.
But then again,
when you hike through the jungle that
there are some tiny or you can see how
that could be because you can't unsee
it.
You know what?
Going to be 10 feet away and sold them a
theme that you have no idea where they
are.
Fucking incredible culture.
It existed here.
What a bizarre,
strange culture that made these,
you know,
these,
these cities that were aligned to like
astronomical,
you know,
points like really amazing,
like he could look the way the sun would
come up through some doorways.
It was like perfectly built.
It's incredible.
It's like the stuff that they had
figured out how to do.
It's like,
how did you do this?
This is amazing.
One of the pyramid,
the bottom of the pyramid,
there's a gigantic store and ahead of as
snake and he's like,
where the hell is the body?
It's like because of that one day of the
year when the standardize,
this eats the shade of the steps in such
a way that it looks like the body's
coming down here.
I mean it's like,
can you imagine like building that whole
thing and then you have like shitty
weather
that would really suck.
Just the calculations involved.
I mean it is it.
Is it possible that some of them could
be coincidental?
I guess the snake thing could be.
It's possible,
but there's so many of them.
There's one in the temple of Luxor.
I think it is,
where the light comes down this corridor
and illuminates his whole room on one
day of the year.
No,
I mean these guys were awesome because
this incredible with the had figured
out.
They've figured out some amazing shit
them in the mind.
It's like so much stuff was lost in the
past would have been so fascinating to
really know what it would.
What,
what?
Like how much knowledge really was
around during the construction of the
pyramids.
I mean,
what did they really know?
How much?
Well,
how much is lost in just the sand and
erosion and how much is gone and fire.
What the fuck did they really know?
You know,
good.
Ninety nine percent of the human
population today with modern technology
and tell them.
Build a pro.
Yeah,
of course.
Nobody.
Yeah.
Everybody liked.
Makes it like it's no big deal.
Canada here.
It's crazy.
If you were asked by just a little bit
anywhere so it gets the top.
It's fucked.
It's amazing.
And they used to be covered in smooth
limestone to east to be shiny and then
there was a gold cap on the top of them.
God Damn.
That must've been magnificent.
Theater Islam.
And what happened if people don't know
you,
look at the pyramids were they're so
fucked up.
That's because people stole the
limestone.
They chipped it off of those buildings.
Those Gross,
disgusting rat people chewed away at
that beautiful construction,
one of the most amazing things a human
being has ever created and they chewed
away it just pulling chunks of beautiful
stone off and building their shitty
houses with it.
Fucking crooks,
rat people.
So you're in a good mood today.
What kind of a human being would deface
the pyramid date?
There were people that did that terrible
human beings.
I mean,
could you imagine,
man,
what kind of a person would fucking chew
up the Pyramids and steal the stone?
Jesus Christ cookies,
your own limestone bench.
You know?
Can you make a house out of wood?
Right.
Even the three pigs had options.
They knew some shit though.
Huh?
That's a fact.
That's what kind of religions
around in ancient Egypt,
like what did they worship?
It was all like hanging around that.
Or you see the transition from tribal
religions that tend to be more mad,
a little flexible because they are not
written down is relatively small
society.
So there's a lot more flexibility about
the beliefs.
So there are generally mystic
shamanistic kind of beliefs,
but then when you turned them into a big
society,
we like millions of people living in it.
They become,
you still have a lot of these traces of
that stuff.
It's all about spirits and these and
that,
but then they become much more hoodie
juvenile fish.
Ow there's a clergy leaders if it comes
and there's the and you know.
So it's kind of a more structured type
of funny museum that in my mind kind of
pretty much hitting mean whatever his
mood about only museum to begin with.
You tweeted a Robert e Dot Howard quote
the other day.
I love that guy.
Oh,
me too.
When I was,
when I was a kid,
I was a huge.
What was the exact tweet?
It was a Conan quote,
unquote.
I forget what the hell it is,
but it's basically cannon going off.
Yeah.
Find it because I'm about to write down
their lies.
Yeah,
it was um,
cone in,
in uh,
it was one of A.
I forget which book,
but it's a famous quote.
Where the fuck is it?
I live,
I burned with life.
I love Islay and damn content
women are like,
that's so gay for a man.
You know the Sumerian culture,
like what a little fucking chrom what a
hard ass God he was.
People don't know Robert e Dot Howard
was as bad motherfucker who's an
incredible author who created.
He created a,
what's called a conquer and Conan the
barbarian.
It was all these crazy fantasy books.
They're amazing.
They're fucking really fun to read.
When I was a kid,
man,
I became hooked on,
on the Conan novels and he was,
uh,
he was uh,
a really nutty dude and wound up taking
his own life.
Right.
I don't know if he's throwing out by the
legend has it that he would say that I'm
at night.
He would see these as he would have got
derrick to it,
right.
And suddenly he would see the shadow
behind him and he wouldn't turn,
but he cooked out that he was calling on
Kevin and John Tax ready to shop.
You set off on last year,
all told night.
And he would stay there and like sweat
that right there.
Right in the morning he was gone.
So he could finally sleep because I know
wouldn't be back ready to shop.
He said,
oh wow.
That was the coolest fucking character
in any book ever written down.
You know,
the people like Conan the barbarian with
Arnold Schwartzenegger.
That was pretty cool and everything like
that.
But really the,
the real.
If someone got ever figured out how to
do the book justice and make it really
put it together,
right?
Like the last one was Kinda corny.
The dude was pretty bad ass.
He was.
That dude was a good call,
man.
He,
he seemed to me like what Kona and
should look like now look great.
But the screenwriting was the screen
writing was bad,
but he was good.
His fight scenes were great.
He looked like Conan,
you know,
I think he people were hating because
he's too fucking good looking.
That's what it is.
The dude is just way too good luck and
you make students super uncomfortable.
But if you,
if you not a hater.
I met the dude,
he was super cool.
And if you're not a hater,
you know,
look man,
he got lucky.
He's born six foot five fucking perfect
chiseled face.
You just got to deal with that bitch.
You gotta deal with that.
But guess what?
That's what Colin and supposed to look
like.
That fucking guy is coming at.
They just need to do it right,
man.
The fucking writing was all corny.
Like the ending was all corny.
What if like Michael Bay did it?
What Dude?
Yeah,
something like that.
Or swords blowing up.
Horses spinning around everybody you
know who would do it right?
Quintin Tarantino.
It right.
Tina would fucking do it.
Right?
He would dig into that bitch and if you
can get Quintin Tarantino to direct the
movie,
God Damn Son.
That would be bad ass.
Show it.
It would be good magic.
Get him to write it to get him to write
the screenplay and put put together like
one of the,
one of the better books.
It was so many good books too.
I gotta give you.
Having Tarantino would be a freaking
dream,
but I like,
I have to say I liked the,
the original Canon.
Yeah.
And I find it interesting that,
that he's the same guy will come up with
some of the concepts were UFC,
you know,
our old gracie said,
but all over it because he wasn't one of
their students of the students off the
graces and he was the gracies.
They had the art Davey and they were
immediately as,
as kind of a creative director or into
the first UFC started coming up with
some of the ideas that then somebody
else designed for the arc that go on and
all of that.
And I'm like,
I love that guy.
He created Conan the barbarian and was
at the beginning of USC.
That's incredible.
I didn't even know that.
That's interesting.
You have some UFC trivia that I didn't
even know that I can go home.
Satisfied now I'm,
my work is done.
Rampage Jackson is mad at me.
Why?
I don't know is an interview.
Read it.
I was watching.
I was just call me fake ass.
And he was saying that shit.
Really?
Yeah.
He was saying that all I want them to do
is throw low kicks and reasoning.
It doesn't throw low kicks is because
he's fighting a wrestler.
You dumb asses.
Look,
man,
you know,
I don't.
I'd love rampage.
I don't mean to be rude when I assess
things.
I'm just trying to objectives.
Really try to figure out how this guy
could be doing better than he's doing.
When I look at a guy like rampage,
I look at a dude with.
He's fucking,
first of all,
one of the most exciting fighters of all
time.
You go back to his fights and pride like
the Ricardo Arona fight or the or the,
the uh,
Kevin randleman knockout.
Remember that?
Random and knockout.
God damn the slam on a roll.
And I meet so many.
He had a great,
great fucking fights in pride.
Know rampage.
I liked him a lot.
I like him as a person.
I enjoyed hanging out with them.
I did a thing with him for the UFC once
it was,
um,
there was a show that we did,
I think it was called ultimately.
Was it ufc ultimate inside or something
like that?
Is that the one we're doing now?
I don't even remember the name of it.
It was,
it was on spike.
Oh fuck.
What was the name of it?
You know,
UFC unleashed is Michael Goldberg's.
What the hell is it called?
Any idea right now?
Alright,
what time at UFC?
Whatever it was.
I don't remember what it was.
Um,
we,
uh,
we drove around in his tracks.
He has this giant monster truck with his
face on the side of it and shit.
It's fucking awesome.
It's hilarious.
It's all lifted and shit.
And we drove around and uh,
I even trained with them.
We went to the gym and trained and we
filmed everything.
We went and got chicken
together and yeah,
we went to popeyes.
He's cool as fuck.
I like them.
I don't mean anything when I,
what I'm trying to,
like when I'm judging a fight or what
not,
I'm not judging a fight,
but when I'm,
when I'm doing commentary and a fight,
all I'm trying to do is sort of
objective,
really assess what I think someone could
be doing differently to try to get
themselves out of a spot if they're not
winning or you know,
I'm just trying to commentate.
It's not,
I'm not like critiquing the guy soul,
I'm not like breaking down who he is as
a person.
I liked the guy a lot,
but even ran pitching himself admits
that he was more exciting back in the
day when he was in.
I mean,
it doesn't have to be.
He's a great fighter.
You can do whatever the fuck he wants.
One,
when I'm doing what I'm doing.
Commentary is just my objective opinion.
That's all it is.
It's not that I don't like the guy.
Why do you think he stopped?
Because even prior to pretty much every
fight he would picked somebody up,
leave them up in the air,
slammed.
I mean it was like he's saying,
do you know he needed every fight?
No facade.
Then never again.
I'm like,
what the hell happened?
I don't know.
I mean he has a lot more tools now.
He's,
you know,
it's,
it's hard to tell him.
Also he was finding people in a ring
more.
I wonder if that's different.
One thing can actually be easier to pick
people up in the cage because they are
age would.
Well He,
you know,
it also you could get fucking after
doing that for a long time.
You could get,
it's possible you could hurt your back,
you could have like issues like a lot of
wrestlers of really powerful guys.
I don't know if he does,
I'm just guessing.
But a lot of guys eventually have like
kinks in their neck and shit.
Tito's had to,
a disc replacement and data wasn't even
lifting people up was just shooting
straight,
lifted some people up to.
He knocked out Evan Tanner,
that was with a big body slam and when
he was younger he would hold these guys
up a lot.
You know,
I think as you get older you get
smarter.
As you get smarter,
you fight more conservatively.
Right.
You know,
but I just wish the guy wasn't mad at me
when I tell them to throw leg kicks,
it's just because he has awesome leg
kicks.
Oh yeah.
Is,
you know,
he's like,
I'm fighting a wrestler.
Dumb ass.
Like I know,
I know I'm Dutch.
I'm just saying man,
he landed a few and his leg kicks are
fucking bad ass.
I would like to see that if I was in his
corner,
you know
when rampage is mad at you,
is that something that you should be
worried about?
Like if you're out and you see them
somewhere and you're like,
oh,
I would talk to him and I'd take,
we'd be cool instantly.
I'm not a,
I'm not a bad person and he's not a bad
person either.
He's just,
he's just upset and he's sensitive and
he's also got the toughest fucking job
on the planet.
There's a lot of pressure and a lot of
stress involved in being a fighter,
you know.
And the last thing I want to do is add
more pressure and add more stress.
All I'm doing is trying to just
analyzing the fight.
That's all it is.
It's just I have to be objective.
I can't,
I can't protect someone's feelings,
you know,
at the expense of doing what I'm
supposed to be doing,
which is sort of analyzing what's going
on,
you know?
And some people say I'm biased and he
was standing a bias towards Jujitsu guys
because yeah,
your lego second deck.
That was cute.
That was funny.
It
was funny,
it was good.
He was animated and Shit.
You know,
he's,
he's a funny guy,
man.
I like rampage.
But if anything I'm more biased.
I always say towards like really
aggressive strikers.
Like vendelay Silva is my favorite all
time fighter.
Rarely.
Yeah,
I think so.
If I had to pick like one guy,
like the vandelay and pride,
he because he was so wild man.
Just every vandelay Silva fight,
you know exactly what the fuck you were
getting into.
It was like a Tyson fight and then that
same sort of feeling.
Right.
You know,
when he was on top,
you know,
when,
when vandelay was just smashed and
dudes,
when he was at his like,
he's very peak.
He was so wild.
Yeah.
It was a wild guy to look.
There was an excitement as a fan,
like holy shit.
You know what I mean with vandelay was
gonna fight man.
Everybody would get hyped up and still
to this day,
like that commonly fight proved it.
Still to this day he's got that,
you know.
So my all time favorite style of
fighting is really not Jujitsu.
I,
you know,
I liked strikers to watch,
I like to,
I still like watching beautiful Jujitsu
technique.
I absolutely do.
But for the Oh shit moments for the Oh
shit,
like almost always chaos.
It's almost hit its head kicks and Mirko
Cro.
Cop was like the king of the Oh shit
moment.
Of course,
you know,
his,
his left high kicks and Fan Angela,
you know,
those are the guys that I always like
really enjoy watching maybe the most,
if anything,
I'm biased towards those guys but I
just,
you know,
I appreciate all of it man.
I appreciate wrestling.
I think wrestling is one of the most
important aspects.
I always show that that's the biggest
base of the pyramid,
you know,
and I was never really a wrestler.
I wrestled for one year in high school.
You know,
it's,
I don't have a bias when I'm looking at
it.
I'm really trying to look at it as
objectively as possible and it changes
all the time or what's important.
It changes all the time because
different levels of guys will enter the
game and that's when things gets weird.
Like gets things get weird,
like when you get like a really high
level striker that all of a sudden
learns how to sprawl and is really good
at wrestling.
Maybe we wrestled a little bit in high
school and then all sudden boom,
he's in the UFC and you got to deal with
this.
Like,
you know,
you get to like a really high level
professional Moitai type fighters who
have really crisp striking.
If one of those guys,
one of those really top end guys,
but one of those are Nesto who slept in
his prime.
One of those guys stepped into the UFC.
Everything changes in that division and
then everybody has to figure that guy
out.
Now you have to,
you know,
everyone has to either evolve around his
skills,
find a way to,
to be able to stand with him.
I hope he gets beat up in the gym,
you know,
shooting before the man.
It's such a,
it's constantly changing.
What's important,
what's important is constantly changing.
Where are we seeing like a new version
like,
oh,
and then what if,
what if one of these guys show site and
then all of a sudden you got this Jon
Jones version,
this new thing,
how do you fucking deal with this?
You've got some young kid who's really
confident,
very smart and has unbelievable
strength,
comes from a background
and has the longest reach of any fucking
human being on the face of the planet is
blasting you and you can even get close
to him and he's getting better every
day.
Every,
every time he blinks he's getting a
little bit better.
You know?
It's ridiculous.
And also he's creative because there are
lots of guys today that are awesome
athletes.
They're great fighters,
but they are kind of boring to watch
because they do what everybody else does
and so,
I mean,
don't get me wrong,
it's like all the respect in the world
because they are doing something
amazing,
but it's not that you'd watch somebody
like Jen Jones so you would watch
Anderson,
CEO of some of these guys.
There's like,
it's a master at work and you sit back
and it's like,
Jesus,
what is going to do now?
You know,
he's an artist.
There's a reason why it's called martial
art.
Martial artists.
That's.
That is exactly what he's doing.
That's artwork,
right?
When you watch his shogun fight,
watch the John Jones shogun fight.
If that's not like a symphony,
it's like a beautiful work of art.
You know what he did is he.
He destroyed one of the best fighters on
the planet and he made it look easy and
it puts it in perspective because you
know,
fucking Leonardo didn't have some six,
four do it,
trying to punch him in the face while he
was painting his masterpiece.
Absolutely believe if you watch the John
Jones Leo Machida fight that that is a
work of art.
I absolutely believe that that's
artwork.
That's fascinating.
The finish was so beautiful.
Everything about it,
everything about the fight is
incredible.
The fact that the yellow tagged him a
few times,
Liotta look great,
but he just,
he caught Leo.
Oh God,
I'm on the ground of days.
I'm on the ground and caught him in that
standing gear,
Tina God damn woo.
But you put it all together like as far
as like,
it's awesome entertainment impact.
You cannot.
That's a work of art,
man.
Absolutely is a different type of art.
I like watching some time somebody's
entire career kind of radar than
watching a bunch of fights from
different people.
Like watch one guy and watch back to
back finds of their stuff and you see
the evolution of their style and you
really see a style.
They're at work and it's,
it's awesome.
Yeah.
That is a fascinating thing to watch
guys evolve.
You know,
I remember Anderson Silva's first couple
of fights when he first started fighting
in pride.
He was primarily a standup guy and he
had submitted,
when he went to the ground,
like Takahashi,
I think it was,
got him in a mounted triangle and then
um,
with wrestling shoes on,
I think he did was hit Takahashi.
Now somebody,
uh,
some dude who had a losing record of all
the things,
the same guy.
You.
No thinking about shown it before,
um,
before,
uh,
he's the same guy.
You'll meet Carlos Newton by decision
and in one of the Bushido events that
cause it.
That's it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now that's awesome.
Yeah,
and so he mounted them and guide them in
a triangle.
And then Rio.
Joanne got him in that flurry flying.
He'll book.
You never seen Anderson Silva lost in
one of the most spectacular finishes of
all time.
It doesn't get any better than that.
I'd be stewed Rio shown and fluid him
sideways,
tied his legs up together in the
scissors like a movie that's like some
shit from a movie that's like some shit
from a pro wrestling show.
And then caught him in this
flying.
He'll hook and Anderson like immediately
tapped in screaming in pain,
you know,
that's really the best submission I've
ever seen.
Crazy.
And there's anything that craziness.
And on top of it I apparently Anderson's
foot was fucked up when it was going
into that fight.
It looked like the second he touches him
and is already tapping and screaming and
going crazy.
Apparently.
Yeah.
He went into that fight with a fucked up
foot.
That's why he wasn't.
He wasn't moving so well.
Yeah.
That's what it looked like.
So that guy goes from that and then all
of a sudden he fights in the UFC against
Chris Leben and now you see this master,
you know,
you see like,
wow,
like the way he took leaving a part like
this is a master,
you know,
the way he moved when he liked
everything leaving through,
he's like shocked out of the way,
encountered Bam,
Bam,
Bam.
These just precise counters and lievens
charging forward and he's blasting them
with kicks and knees and punches and
you're like,
God damn is he good?
Holy Shit.
His fight for as good a fiend.
I mean I do.
What the hell can you say?
Well,
you know,
one of the interesting thing is that
forest,
I had an interview with him about that
and he told me that he had gotten
knocked out twice in training camp
before that fighting.
So right.
Right away he probably shouldn't have
even been in it.
Right.
You know?
I mean,
if you get knocked down in a training
camp like two times,
how many concussions are you allowed to
have like really close back to back,
right?
That already are disclosed to somebody
touching you the right away and you're
like,
well,
there's been a few fighters that have
had that happen to them and they both
got knocked out exactly the same way.
One of them was a,
there was a dude who was fighting in the
UFC for awhile.
Um,
fuck was Marvin Eastman.
Marvin Eastman got knocked out.
He was a.
He got caught by Travis.
What the fuck's his name?
Luther Travis Luder.
Of course,
Jesus Christ.
How can I forget that guy's name?
Who's sick?
Jujitsu guy,
but not really known for being like a
super powerful striker,
real strong guy.
I can't believe I forgot his name.
Travis.
I'm so sorry.
I love that guy.
Actually,
I just had too much weight.
Do I blame it on the weed?
That's way too much weight and really
strong.
I've been sitting here stone like a
crazy person over here.
Yeah.
It's not good for your brain.
Stuff's terrible for him.
Anyway,
Travis Luder caught Marvin eastern with
a right hand and just like at the end of
the punch and eastern went down like he
got shot,
but he got snipe from a,
from a fucking tower.
It was a.
He had gotten knocked out twice in
training camp as well by a.
He was a knockdown once,
I think by Tito Ortiz accidentally ran
into a knee and knocked down another
time when I take down attempt so you
know when that's happening,
man,
you,
you know you can get knocked out super
easy.
It's big enough.
MMA and religion.
That was one of my favorite moments ever
when a eastern mountain lost a fight to
vitor belfort,
did that crazy knee and sprite and then
they added the cameras in the post fight
interview on Belford saying thank you
Jesus for giving me the strength to do
what I do.
And then they pan on.
Marvin eastern phases like you
sold that is pretty top one looks at a.
I think you said,
if I remember correctly,
you said he looked like a good spot,
Diana,
which has the best line server,
but it's really,
really unfortunate that I actually saw
that it just kept it to myself and you
see Belfort going out about Jesus giving
him the strength that you see somebody
had been plead with blood everywhere and
you're like,
really?
That's what was going on.
But I thought that was pretty funny,
but that'd be a good guy.
But I think a lot of fighters really,
uh,
liked to believe in the Lord and like
to,
you know,
to be on a good path because first of
all,
I think it helps their fighting.
I think a lot of guys who were
Christians,
you know,
they have a little bit of extra faith.
They have a little bit of extra
calmness,
like extra belief in themselves.
If you truly are a believer,
there is a benefit to that psychological
as a tool,
right?
That's why do exist for edits and Dane
doesn't look like it makes sense,
but that's why it succeeds because he'd
believers the huge benefit.
It helps people be disciplined and stay
on certain paths,
you know,
helps people,
uh,
you know,
stay on,
uh,
if you,
if you really truly believe in a higher
power,
you know,
it's much more likely that you're going
to have a,
at least some sort of a code that you're
living by.
Right?
Does that make sense?
Totally.
What is it possible to live life like?
It'd be really nice without that mean is
it possible to give Vince people to live
like a,
like,
you know,
live like a free person,
but also live within principles of
decency and just abandoned everything
else.
I'm very much thing so,
but it takes,
um,
it takes special people because not
everybody can handle it because a lot of
people,
unless you keep them in a little cage,
dale go crazy and do all sorts of messed
up stuff.
It's kind of like the daoist I left out
is because you see them,
they are.
The first fatality is like,
our staff is,
you need to be smart,
you need to be sensible,
you need to have all these tools that
you don't have.
So go to take confucianism instead,
it's better for you because you won't
fuck things up too bad.
They'll give you a simple rules to
stick,
to limit how much damage you can make.
Confucianism is bad,
therefore you seriously just go there.
Our stuff,
it's too,
you know,
they are elitist.
Obviously they are a little bit with
this,
but so is life,
you know,
not everybody's gonna get it.
That's how it is,
you know,
it takes a hell of a human being to live
with no rules and steel behaving amazing
way,
but that doesn't mean it can be done.
And uh,
so in that sense I find,
you know,
all the rules,
giving her allegiance useful for a
segment of humanity.
But then if you want to talk about full
potential of human beings,
I feel like no,
you can do better than that.
People have a real hard time with that
though.
When you start segmenting human beings
and saying that some people are more
worthy or some people are more capable
or some people are more even evolved.
You know,
I haven't ever last cell so I don't
care.
But I mean to be,
let me explain it so I don't sound too
much like a vassal butts eats,
I believe in being nice to anybody.
Okay?
I don't care.
Meyer stupid,
whatever you should treat everybody
giving them opportunity,
you know,
it's like prove to me that you're not a
moron.
Great.
I'll give you all the opportunities in
the world.
But at the same time I can be delusional
and expect that everybody's going to be
amazingly smart and you walk into any
room and you can throw.
It's like I kind of expect people to
suck,
but I'll give them all the opportunities
in the world to prove otherwise.
And I feel like that weighs a healthy
balance between being realistic about it
and being without turning into a jerk.
You know?
Um,
so you think that if,
if the government came out and said,
hey,
listen,
we,
uh,
we did some studies,
it turns out religions,
totally bullshit.
And we're going to start from scratch
because we don't know what the fuck is
out there.
What percentage of people do think we
just go completely batshit crazy and
riot in the streets?
Would it be any,
would anything change it on isn't not
based on evidence anyway,
so it doesn't matter what anybody tells
you.
You a lot of people wouldn't be marching
through the street.
That would be one way where people would
like really show how much they believe
in March.
They would start marching through the
streets.
They would organize it,
would really put out a message,
but that's one of the coolest things
about living in us today.
The in general in the Western world,
you'll find a few.
Not even that long hand.
They're 200 years ago they were,
you know,
you'll burn people on the public square
kind of thing.
They,
they disagreed today.
Even the hardcore fundamentalist,
they got all riled up and they got
piece,
but they are not the Taliban,
you know,
they may think like them,
but they don't act like them,
but we were trying to stop it from
getting any further than this.
It's anybody that has that much faith in
what they can't see.
That's,
that's,
that's a disturbing thing.
You're willing to die for this.
That's an issue,
so they're willing to die.
Part of worries me is you're willing to
kill whatever you know.
It's your life willing to enforce your
ideas.
Yeah.
The one that pissed me off the master of
this things is the euthanasia debate.
The fact that today in 2012 with the
technology that we have where you could
let people die in a good way,
you could black,
you know somebody say,
look,
when I get to that point,
I want to be able to shoot me an
injection.
You put me to sleep.
You give me the other one that puts me
out without being,
yeah,
that's their damn life.
Nobody's saying that you need to die
that way.
You want to go in whatever way you want
to go,
good for you,
but you really want to tell everybody
else how they die.
It's a tricky thing,
man,
because I think there's a lot of people
that have cranky old grandparents push
them motherfucker into that bed.
I go,
look,
he's been delusional right now,
but he's been telling us to kill him for
a couple of days.
Just going to go ahead and do this,
but there's the double thing.
You have either people should do when
they are young,
what do you want to do in x amount of
situations and sign it.
Then the one that are less,
they change their mind,
but that's what stakes or they pick
somebody that the same way as they pick
somebody to manage their bank accounts.
They picked somebody who can make those
kind of decisions.
Wow.
Because otherwise really you are in the
position where today you have a sick
dog,
you can take them to the vet and they
are gone in no time with no pain,
but for human being,
you have to suffer every step of the way
senior,
your body go to crap and it's very
uncomfortable with giving somebody the
power to shut off a life.
We're very uncomfortable with it.
Right?
It's tricky and in my mind is that's you
know,
when you love somebody,
you care for somebody and you see them
go down that path and that's what they
want.
That's the biggest thing you can do for
them.
Just let them die the way they want.
Yeah,
no,
I see what you're saying.
I mean,
I,
I agree with you,
but I think people,
like I said,
are very uncomfortable with the idea,
especially religious folks.
Yeah,
it's God the side when you get to yours,
so let you waste away for six more
months in order.
But essentially they do kill you anyway
with painkillers.
You know,
with a lot of people when they,
when it's towards the end,
keep flooding you with painkillers.
It's not pleasant because he's not that.
They don't feel anything or they don't
realize that anything they do realize
that feel,
don't realize it.
So it's like it's not a productive way
to go.
Fuck,
I'm over the school of thought and just,
you know,
just what happens when they cure that.
What happens when people don't get old?
How many goddamn people are going to be
here?
If they figured out how to stop people
from getting old and dying,
we might have a real problem.
We might not even.
We might have to build spaceships,
see it as well.
There are too many people just at that
point or will be more and more and more
if we start dying and keep people kept
fucking right would be nuts.
Jesus Christ at that point is where you
can have the UFC have,
uh,
you know,
give a sword to some dudes,
put them in a cage and everything,
go at each other for any show you know,
you have a disagreement with anybody or
anything.
Please circle it with swords in the
cage.
And it sounds really stupid to say,
you know,
that people would devolve to that level,
but when you get like a lot of people
together,
they sort of devalue each other when you
have too many of them in the,
uh,
that deposit it in the future and
radiation sickness and who knows what
the fuck's going to be going on now?
Life becomes cheap people.
It's kind of like even in the ancient
world where people die left and right
all around and people were a lot less
sensitive about a human life where you
could have the gladiator or some people
clap and think it's cool because it's
like they see people dying left and
right all the time,
hey,
at least you got to die.
After you train a bunch of minds.
You look like a hero,
Eh,
you've got your head chopped off,
but hey,
you know you are going to die anyway,
six months in some other way,
so might as well.
Isn't it amazing when you really stop
and think about it?
Isn't it incredible that people ever got
past ancient Rome we ever got to today?
Think how nutty those assholes were?
The people were finding lines with
swords and shit.
Do it throw lines at people.
God Damn what?
A bunch of crazy assholes.
Two weeks ago some guy emails me from
the history channel and say,
are you by any chance an expert on
Caligula the Roman emperor?
And like,
not really.
I mean,
I read to my Roman historian stuff,
but he's like,
perfect.
Just come on,
read my email,
it's like,
Yo,
you sound great because you've known
you've got a book that you looked at
once.
So I was an expert on Caligula.
The history channel is awesome.
It was,
but it was cool actually.
They did their homework.
I read all their stuff.
They was all on the spot,
you know,
funnier than the history channel when
they got to do that.
Comes onto sasquatch expert.
Right.
Like what it's been lately.
And how,
so,
so how much did you have to know for
them to use you?
You know,
I was actually surprised that I knew
more than I thought I did,
but you know,
it's not like I'm the expert because I
wanted to highlight or add something.
But then I was like,
hey man,
I don't remember all this stuff.
Did you have to research it before?
I was like,
cool shit.
They bet their homework,
you know?
So I did that.
He read the whole thing and everything
and to make the connection fast there.
So you don't think about it for five
needle.
It's going,
uh,
you know,
but Culligan man,
crazy motherfucker.
That guy was,
I don't mind sort of wild,
I mean Caligula was sort of,
you know,
to the 10th power,
but Roman Culture in general,
Jesus Christ,
this guy's were violent with pointed.
I mean,
you know,
today there's the,
uh,
you shoot it and killed people in ways
that are cruel and unusual.
All of them,
they are all about,
you know,
the more violent,
painful and public we can make it,
the better it will make a statement to
the fact that you don't fuck with the
state.
That's bizarre.
Virta,
how did Brian Go?
That was,
that's what you get for shit.
And outside of that bathroom right
there.
She just went right there.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that,
that break in the podcast was Brian got
locked outside and he was banging on the
door.
Sorry,
Brian,
you silly goose it.
Comedy Club has like these automated
locks when they're closed.
And so I went out to go because we're
not supposed to shit in his bathroom.
So because it shits and makes everybody
smell the shit.
Right?
But no one's working today.
There were some people here are the
word.
Okay.
So I didn't want.
Alright,
so where were we?
Where were we talking about?
Crazy Romans.
Oh yeah.
How,
how amazing that culture was.
A bunch of savages.
People got through that.
That's we our ancestors of people.
You know,
some,
some of us are at least of of people
that live there.
It's not like people went extinct back.
No.
Far From It.
What a,
what a weird time that have been.
Huh?
What a ship roll.
The dice that is getting born and you're
living in ancient Rome.
It was spun out.
UFC started both the people who hated it
and the people who loved it compared to
the gladiators gladiator opening.
We,
we just abandoned it into the new one is
fucking crazy and seemed unusual or new
ones.
Amazing.
But the,
the,
the gladiator opening was on for a long
time.
Everyone's just like,
who is this gladiator dude?
What is all this about?
Rubbing dirt in his hands and shit.
And it was just like,
what,
you know with the Italian music,
you know?
And then it's the opening onto the,
the new.
The new opening.
Is Wick it though?
Yeah.
Huh?
The gladiators,
what was Caligula's deal quickly.
It was completely out of his fucking
mind basically.
Was He,
do you think he was clinically insane or
you think it was just mad with power?
I think that's the beginning of it.
Then of course,
you're gonna operate in an environment
where,
uh,
you know,
your Ankle Keel,
soul of your family or brothers and
sisters and her mom to the point that
she was a scenario and then gets there
to start to that,
you know,
that's the environment you grew up
around Jesus,
even if you are totally saying you
started going elite along over the edge,
why they do that to everybody because
they are a main bus starts and uh,
they protected their own power and
anybody that they felt could be a threat
to their power,
they would get rid of them in fairly
nasty ways.
Price.
No,
he's no different than any gang or any,
you know,
it's human nature that way.
Where at its worse.
Yeah,
because there was no rules.
Essentially they were,
they were calling the shots.
It's amazingly,
people ever get to a point of royalty
that people allow that hustle.
You know?
It's a very strange hustle that even
though there's no fucking food,
everybody's starving.
No one,
you know,
there's no prosperity.
There's no books.
People are so silly.
They'll believe that this one guy is
worth more than everybody else controls
their armies and he's their noble leader
and.
But that would.
That would be a cool job.
I sign up for that after you guys pulled
that job off and then somebody would
kill you with a sword.
I think today I started,
well,
I started saying,
no,
most people suck and I have a disability
thing that I want to be the king of the
universe.
That would be great.
That I think every smart person thinks
that there would be an awesome king.
I would be different.
Listen,
there's a lot of things.
It'd be assholes or I was the king.
That's how every cart gets caught,
gets started,
right?
Some guy comes along and goes,
listen,
these other cults,
they don't fuck their doors the way I
would do it.
All needs to the lab really nice and as
long as I'm uncontrolled,
trust me or I'm really,
really honest and objective about this.
When is,
when are we going to fucking figure this
out?
So I got my results back for my physical
Joe.
And you had a physical.
I guy at full physical.
They tested blood every month and they
said that I'm like 100 percent.
Everything's fine.
My cholesterol.
It's exactly perfect.
Like the only thing that was bad,
he's like,
just take a little bit of d,
You don't get how much do you.
And I'm like,
no,
I don't cut out.
So he's like,
just get some over the counter,
dee the you'll be fine,
but you're just a slight.
No,
that's good.
That's good.
And no stds.
My first AIDS test mooching off of a
test,
but you got a real one now.
Congratulations.
I'm glad you know Diane.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
that is good.
That's a monkey off your back,
right?
Totally.
That's,
you know,
I kind of feel like I eat somewhat
healthy.
Like what I'll do is I'll eat healthy
and then I'll have a shitty day where
I'll eat fucking pizza.
You know?
So it,
I think I have the a good up and down.
Isn't it crazy that your va,
your body actually produces a vitamin by
looking at the sun?
Yeah.
You're out in the sun.
Your body produces vitamin D.
that's why when you see like George St
Pierre,
when he's fighting and he gets Tan,
that getting pampered like that is
actually actually makes you perform
better.
There's nothing nuts.
That fucking crazy.
Getting a Tan actually makes you perform
better as a fighter.
Like what?
What is the bad part about having a tea?
Not Much d though.
Like if you were an extreme case,
would you just be like,
oh I can't.
Yeah,
you'd be fucked.
It's really bad for you.
I really.
Yeah.
I think that's an issue with the people
that live in really cloudy climates as
well.
Like Seattle.
Yeah,
I bet they have a problem.
We keep going.
Just Seattle today.
Seattle called them heaven.
See Cock.
Seattle is a cool place.
Well,
how dare you.
Yeah,
I look so beautiful up there.
Oh by the way,
somebody told me they just got back
again from Tempe or Phoenix,
Arizona and went to that new club and an
Arizona.
It is the most amazing place ever and
that you would love it.
It's 600 seats,
but they have.
They have like a person that follows you
around let's like your own like,
Hey,
can I get you something?
Like you each have your own individual,
individual person,
a Sam triple.
He went there and just had like a crazy
party.
He said it was.
He saw somebody doing shit in the
elevator,
this elevator walk up and then people
were having sex in it and stuff.
It says it's awesome.
It's a party.
So check that it's the,
you know the one I'm talking about right
there,
having sex there.
What's going on?
Why don't want to give away Sam story
because he hasn't said it yet because he
has a naughty show at night.
So.
Oh,
so he's going to say it tonight?
I think so it's just how many podcasts
are you doing in this day?
Three today.
Should we?
How?
How are you going to listen to other
people talk?
It's impossible.
How can you.
How are you going to do this?
You gotta you gotTa shut your ears off
after awhile.
Huh?
Do you go numb?
Just know it's just kind of meditate.
Well,
listen to it,
you know.
Wow.
It's a lot of jobs aren't guest.
We need to have a religious question and
answer podcasts with you.
How about that?
Let's do the shit would not be fucking
bad ass.
How people that have questions to
religion,
they contact you and then they could buy
your books to what is,
what is your one that you published
recently on disinfect?
What is that called?
It's called the 50 seats.
They are not supposed to know religion.
And the genesis of this was kind of
interesting because originally phd from
book about religion and he was,
you know,
these big,
thick,
heavy book and that they are like,
yeah,
you know,
that's sweet,
but we're in the business of selling
books.
So give us something,
you know,
what is the big thick work?
What was that going to be about?
It was,
um,
that's kind of looking at
old basically what the approach that
Bruce Lee added to martial arts,
I was trying to play,
adapted to religions,
sort of like taking a bunch of different
religions to look at what all the big
questions are a look at what some of the
answers that are out there to make up
your own thing as you go.
And uh,
because ultimately to me that's the only
thing that anybody does,
you know,
it's,
I'm making call Legion college
philosophically.
Whatever makes you feel good about
bottom line is a way of life.
And so I was like,
do your own work to see what's out there
and come up with your own answers that
way.
And actually now that we did this one,
they decided to go for it.
So I think I will publish the other one
toward the end of the year,
you know,
in end of 2012.
So this would be a really big book.
They asked me to cut it a bit and it's a
good idea because there's too much stuff
and people will be like halfway through
what I go back.
It's no more but uh,
so yeah,
I'll do that one,
cutting it a bit and um,
so that one I was super excited about,
but back then they are actually smart
because they know that this kind of
stuff,
sales because he's um,
quicker,
funny,
weird,
random,
informative stories in and out,
you know,
you read the one next,
you don't feel like you're liking that
one,
boom.
You jump to the next one.
So there's 50 of them and uh,
but yeah,
it was,
it was weird because when I originally
signed up to do it,
that was in as now I'm really happy I
did it when I started,
I was like,
Eh,
I needed money.
I guess so sure.
What the hell,
why not?
But in my initial mom and Danny was in a
shitty period of my life because I
signed on,
it was like January 2011 or something
and I said sure,
I'll get it done.
And they like do it by April.
Like okay,
that's a little tight,
but sure I can do it.
Then that's when everything went to shit
with my wife,
six weeks in the hospital,
horrible things.
And then the second one though that was
over,
I'm now responsible for a 19 month old
baby to deal with there all the time and
I have a Montana enough read left to
right this stuff.
And I'm like,
Shit.
Now that's intense.
And um,
but the thing is generally,
I mean I break more laws than I can keep
track of,
but one thing I do is I don't break my
word ever.
And I told them,
you know,
I'll get it done.
They were even being nice about it.
They were like,
we can push the deadline,
but like,
no man,
you know,
you wanted it done by then even eats
good for me.
It gives me something to focus on.
Right?
So they do dan being there,
you know,
contemplating my navel thinking the
word.
So I have something to do.
And not only that,
but it has to be funny,
lighthearted at a time when my life is
really not needed or funny or
lighthearted and sweets.
It was actually good therapy for me
because I could,
uh,
you know,
while I'm giving my daughter meal come
thinking about what the hell is the next
line and I get to make it snappy,
fast fashion,
but funding,
but I think I could do for myself
because I'm,
you know,
as soon as you write while you were
holding the baby,
as he literally got to the why where I
would dream about what I was going to
write at night.
I would fall asleep.
Like I finish writing,
I pass out,
I dream about what I'm going to write
when my baby wakes up.
I'm like holding their feeding around.
Like,
okay,
look at that thing over the next line,
you know?
And then the second one she would sleep.
That's when I would write the most.
Of course I would be like,
go,
go.
Okay.
Now bus out next day.
Wow.
What a crazy fucking schedule.
How long did you do that for?
A couple of months.
It was maybe two other than to win
enough months.
That's how long it took to make the
book.
Well,
so it's 50 things that you're not
supposed to know about religion.
It's called give us one of them.
What's a good one to see?
What's fun?
Let's stick a big men coming up with the
titles was half of the phone.
I'm,
I keep myself operating them.
I have one chapter I think is kind of
the stuff I was telling you earlier is
called.
If you are too stupid for them,
you can always try confucianism.
That's always would make me popular in
China.
Uh Oh,
this is great.
There's this guy,
um,
the title of this one is God is wearing
dragon robes and wants you to keep
confusion.
Assess.
This is an awesome story.
Is in the 89,
this one,
a Chinese guy became converted to
Christianity and he started saying that
he was Jesus' younger brother,
that you had this vision of God that was
wearing dragon polo shirts and told them
that Buddhism and Confucianism or crap
and it was his duty to stamp them out.
So he got their APP or this follower
started preaching in the countryside,
gain all these people.
They became so powerful that they carved
out their own state within China and
they said that this was going to be,
I forgot what it's called.
It's something that I have to find it
because there's just too good,
but he was called something along the
lines like a,
the evan leaking dome of everlasting
peace or something.
Well,
the heavenly kingdom of everlasting
peace ended up with the debt of 20
million people in the course of civil
wars between the Chinese government or
was pieced over these guys thrown into
Medicare way and these kind of weird
version of a Chinese fundamentalist
Christianity fighting against that.
His guys.
And eventually when they laid siege to
the CT,
he was telling his followers,
don't worry,
God is on our side.
And of course he died shortly thereafter
by eating some boys on Missouri by
mistake.
And um,
and that was that.
What year was this all going down?
I want to say meet 89,
I think.
18,
2017.
30.
And how many people died in this
conflict when t me $20 million.
Yeah.
So one dude came along saying that he
was Jesus his brother and 20 million
people died as a result of this one guy.
Is that essentially what you're saying?
Yeah.
Typing,
going on 1858 and 64.
And um,
yeah,
that's.
And that's why is not supposed to know.
He's like,
I've never heard about that.
That's such an immense number of people
that died.
I mean,
what they fuck they get the numbers we
had the benefit of the doubt is maybe 50
meters old.
How knows?
But you know,
that's what some people have speculated
that the number was.
And how would they know?
Right.
20 million people's a guests back then,
right?
Of course.
And uh,
but he's brutal civil war racking China
for a band,
which is one of the reasons why a bunch
of Chinese people migrated to California
at the time when there was the gold rush
is because south China was get the
indirect left and right.
What's this dude's name again?
Uh,
the guy's name was hung to something
that's going to be a lot of people.
Gonna want to play that guy on like
video games.
It's going to be their name.
Go on as this bad motherfucker convinced
a bunch people.
He was Jesus,
his brother.
Shit.
I have no idea how to pronounce it.
That's a high level pimp game right
there.
Sign Hong does.
She would try and I have no idea.
It's hard to pronounce.
I make it tough.
How do you spell it?
It's age.
Well,
Chinese is spelled two different ways
depending on now you,
but the one that we're using was h o n g
and that's one word.
And then the next word is x.
i,
u q u a n.
wow.
So good luck fixing on this.
It's really fascinating the way the
Chinese have a language,
you know,
it's phonetic obviously because if
they're,
they have totally different characters
that we have,
but the way they've expressed it in like
the letters that we use.
So it's bizarre really.
Some of the words are really strange,
especially like with x's and them and
shit.
My wife,
my wife is Chinese and she was trying to
teach me some Chinese and I was like,
I mean I couldn't say it because she
kind of hated Japanese people,
but I was thinking,
Jesus,
couldn't you just be Japanese is so much
easier.
Japanese is easier to learn.
Easier.
It's the way you read it,
it's kind of the way you pronounce it.
There's only one toe on it.
It's easier.
Chinese is the same exact ward with tiny
different tax.
That means completely different things.
And there are like four different tax
ids for each ward.
Oh No.
It's just like,
oh no.
Can anybody say anything?
So you think it's more complicated than
English?
English is a hard one to learn though
for some reason.
I mean I'm sure if that's where you come
from,
if you speak Chinese or something,
yeah,
English must be a pain in the ass,
but for anybody coming from a vaguely
Latino background or anything,
any of the Western languages trying to
pick up chain,
any tonal language like Chinese,
Vietnamese,
some of those,
it's just like that.
It is pretty fucked up that we all speak
different languages.
How many,
you know,
I mean,
how many problems would be solved if
everybody spoke one language that would
be nice to solve anything at this point
in time would it?
People hate each other from New York to
Irvine,
so you don't.
You don't have to,
but it would out.
You will be better than nothing.
That's for sure.
It is pretty crazy how different
languages are too.
I mean the difference between like
Chinese and Norway,
Norwegian and Chinese accuser in a
bigger difference.
Is it even possible to get something
more Chinese and you know,
how about Chinese and African tribal
languages for.
They're all.
They don't have the.
Yeah.
Awesome.
That's fascinating man.
It's just so incredible how it evolves
differently in different areas,
but it all evolves.
You know,
how many different languages are there?
Are there hundreds?
Thousands.
I'm going to go on some bullshit guys
since say what?
Surviving today because of course their
languages,
but wait,
wait,
but let me bullshit first.
Let's try surviving today.
I want to say
say
the wind,
they're 50.
I'll say
176,
I'll say a thousand.
I think you're actually closer.
The more I'm thinking about it because
there are a bunch of languages in the
world.
Oh my God.
They between six thousand eight hundred
and six thousand nine hundred distinct
languages.
The modern world.
Holy Shit.
Where we off?
You are the closest dude.
Yeah,
but I,
I thought I thought I overshot it to be
honest with you.
I thought it was probably around 900.
Right?
Holy Shit.
That's incredible.
Well,
I mean 90 percent of that or languages
that are dying that are like 30 people
in a tribe is still speak and clicking
noises,
clicking noises.
Well,
how bizarre is that when they have
places,
like there's some spots in the Amazon
that they're,
you know,
just just recently discovered people in
these tribes and the,
this is the first contact that they're
having with the modern world and they're
in there with their own wacky language
that they sit at.
One of the few guys have had some
contact with them.
They promptly killed him.
So yeah.
Good luck making contact again.
The someone made contact with him,
there was one guy who was like an India
from a different tribe,
so he kind of understood their language,
but she also was,
you know,
more immersed into mother and Lord and
they'll have less.
So he was kind of like in transition
between those two words and they.
Yeah,
they killed.
Nobody knows why,
but yeah,
they walked him.
Well,
I think they probably have heard that
some shit goes down when the loggers
move in and you know that that is what
happens to these people probably.
Yeah.
There's w.
What folks don't know is there was a,
a bunch of people living.
I mean they are people.
They're living like people used to live
thousands of years ago.
They're,
they're essentially essentially,
you know,
living in ancient tribal lifestyle that
we didn't really even think existed
anymore.
They have their own handmade tools and
weapons and you know,
they're wearing like fucking crazy
leaves on their dicks and shit and
animal skins and it's there and they're
still in there.
And then these people who are logging
are going deeper and deeper into the
forest and they're just cutting down at
an astounding rate.
Yeah.
And there's all these incredible
medicines to be found there and all
these different and animals that haven't
even been discovered yet and insects
that haven't been discovered yet.
And who knows what the fuck's in there
and they're just shopping that shit down
and left and right.
And these people oftentimes are getting
caught up in this where,
you know,
they had,
they lived there in that forest and that
deep in there for thousands of years.
And then all of a sudden one day they
wake up and they're fucking,
they're there watching trees fall in the
distance,
you know,
like what the fuck is going on?
And they just coming towards you.
It's an inevitable swarm of tree eating
machines and there are all these people,
these greedy people behind them and they
don't want to move around you and
they're going to chop your fucking trees
down.
Get outta here.
Yeah.
That's living like a savage.
They're looking at him like you're
looking like a fucking.
He live in like a savage on here.
What the fuck you doing?
Trapping and shit down.
We have all those people had a wild life
for a long time.
Who's to say their life isn't more
interesting.
This is doing Iowasca and fishing and
shit.
You know what I'm saying?
If you're pretty dope,
you know what I mean?
If you get used to living in the jungle,
it's a hard,
hard life,
but there's a lot of food there.
You know,
you could become it.
You could become food fucked up that to
zig when he should've zagged.
There's a thing called a Brazilian
wondering spider that kills you by
giving you an erection until you die.
It's fucking,
it has something to do with nitric oxide
and uh,
which is like the same stuff that's in
the works and like Viagra and stuff that
makes your dick hard.
And apparently this,
um,
this spider hits you with it and it
causes some crazy fucking reaction.
It's neurotoxin.
It's the most powerful neurotoxin.
None of the man and your whole body just
completely stiffens up and horrifying
agony.
And your Dick gets hard as fuck so hard.
It's like breaking like your Dick is in
gorged and breaking and even if you
survive it,
which most people don't survive,
but even if you do survive,
your Dick will be destroyed.
The deq would be useless.
It would just be a bag of bruises.
Sound like fun.
That's just from one bite from one,
but what if it just linked you and then
you just had a really hard boner all the
time in their life.
Doesn't work that way if you just got a
little bit.
It doesn't work that way,
but I do believe that
pharmaceutical companies are like
investigating the effect that this thing
has on your body to develop new hard on
medication.
Yeah.
You know,
developed substrate that gives you a
hard on for a year.
They're going to do.
That's the next thing you know,
like Viagra is like,
it's not effective enough.
What if I want to fuck 12 hours from now
I need.
I need something a little more kick to
it,
and they came up with Cialis.
They'll have like jeans will have these
new pockets there.
These tubes that just kind of go up to
the side where you just put your dick in
during the day because you have a rock
part.
You don't want to,
you know,
you're gonna have a boner everyday
tubes,
you know,
like you'll have like a little pocket to
put your ticket.
They'll start selling new pockets and
their tools trap.
Right,
so it can move around with you.
Yeah.
It's like a cargo pant pocket for your
deck there.
You're going to have to just point it up
towards your belly button.
Go over the top.
As you're walking everywhere,
all the articles are going to have a
belt buckle marks.
Periscopes there can start forming
different.
That might be actually the most
comfortable with.
If you could just walk it straight up.
Yeah.
Just some sort of a tent.
Put a dick tent over it.
You know,
I know exactly what you mean.
That's
in the jungle though.
Maybe the.
Maybe these nice lagers are saving these
people for the life of perpetual.
Yeah.
Death by hard on in the jungle.
You ever see that movie?
Big River Man.
No documentary about some crazy guy who
swam the length of the Amazon River.
It's disgusting.
Why did you got all kinds of fucking
parasites?
His skin and his body and his breathing
and drinking that water,
taking it in and Oh my God,
it's because he's crazy.
He just is really,
really funny,
crazy guy who liked to swim and be like,
do these swim endurance things and uh,
you know,
he would do it day after day after day
and he would,
he's getting delirious and shit.
It's a really strange,
like documentation on this guy.
He's like,
he had done a bunch of different
endurance swims before and you know,
get all these people behind them and
it's a documentary that's taken by his
son.
It's really interesting because his son,
you know,
is like watching this guy do all this
nutty shit and sort of falling apart and
all the different parasites he's getting
from this water.
Oh fucking crazy man.
I can imagine that you're,
you know,
that's your father and you'll keep it up
camera and going for the next 20 days as
the.
It's just,
well not only that,
he would like jump off the boat into the
night in the middle of the night and
start swimming and then have to follow
after him with spotlights and shit.
This crazy ass hole with this crocodiles
out there and this guy is swimming in
the Nile River and he survived.
He survived.
Yeah.
Fascinating.
You know,
and he actually kind of looked like once
he cleaned up and dried out and
everything like that,
he actually looked like you made it
through.
Okay.
Which is even more crazy.
Yeah.
That isn't that.
Yeah,
there's just some dudes out there,
but I mean that's the random.
And so he told you,
you know,
you're going to fucking die in the
safest place in the water because
everybody could fall on you or
something.
Or you can sweeten the Amazon for
thousands of miles and come out fine.
It's like,
what the fuck,
man.
Really.
It's a weird thing that people have for
wanting to do difficult things.
You know?
I tell him,
I've always felt that way about like
Mount Everest.
I had a joke about it.
Like it's just because something's hard
to do doesn't mean it's good to do.
See people get a little confused.
It is because the difficult things to do
in this life usually come with reward.
You know,
your risk yourself,
you know,
you leave your job,
you start your own business and that
reward is how it worked and now you're
making it financially.
Graduations you're a success.
There was a risk and there's reward in
that case.
That's not,
that doesn't look like the reward is
worth it.
No,
no,
no.
If you could stop
put,
letting.
Is there a way that you could ever say
that anyone running for president cannot
talk about religion?
It's almost like even if you believe,
it's almost like you shouldn't be
allowed to talk about it in the
political process.
It's almost like cheating,
you know,
it's almost like you're not,
you're,
you're going after your people,
man.
You just trying to get your people
divorce,
like will do it.
Of course.
That's our little chunk of fewer
opioids.
There's a.
It was supposed to be that way though,
wasn't it?
Yeah.
This time.
Uh,
yeah.
But I mean,
I think honestly what happened is that
Utopian about,
so could they offer early dress waters
for so long that they,
people got really annoyed by it.
He was like,
I'm done enough of this shit.
They were chopping each other's bowls.
So the fact that you would read this
book and I read this one hour about what
you do,
whatever the hell do you want to,
let's keep it already John Sattler for
politics and be done with it.
You know.
And so today in a lot of Europe you go
to churches and they are a tourist
attraction and so,
you know,
in the countryside now people are still
into it,
but in most of the cte seats they read
our knocked.
Most people don't go us whole different
game I think is the only modern
industrialized country where there's
these levels of insane embark on their
religion.
I mean today there is no way that a good
Aha guy equal never even bother running
for president is.
Has there ever been a time where an
atheist could have ran for president and
not anyone else?
No,
never.
I mean,
some guys where we are like Thomas
Jefferson or something,
he basically 83rd the Bible by cutting
up all the stuff that he thought was
crap,
which was most of it and saving,
you know,
like he took out out of the gospels.
He took out the virgin birth,
the miracles,
the,
all of the stuff that he knew his mind
was a bunch of crap.
He saved up the pirates of Jesus that he
likes saying he's,
he's a sweet guy.
He tells you to be nice to each other.
I like that part where we keep it up.
Art and that became the Jefferson Bible.
He said he said averse.
How long was his Bible?
Like 50 patients bridge much.
But I don't remember how long ago it was
about and what a cocky dude.
Yeah.
Things.
But at the same time he was a dick.
I mean,
it's probably a dick at the same time.
Uh,
you know,
come on man.
You can't edit that thing,
but you know what,
you don't get to edit it by yourself.
The fact is everybody does.
They just don't tell you because,
you know,
everybody highlights the power day like,
and they completely keep on the parts
they don't like and so they come up with
their own thing anyway.
At least the guy who had the guts to
say,
this is exactly what I'm doing.
What everybody else does it,
they just,
you know.
Well,
there's always so much contradiction.
Then.
How about religious tattoos?
That's like strictly prohibited.
I know that's crazy,
but when the Bible,
yeah,
you'll get the,
you'll get that.
In fact that we have,
for example,
a lot of Jewish people know what that
tool is not on the,
you get,
um,
you get all the sinks,
like a white Jewish
girls with tattoos at hot.
But she's a gambler.
Just rolling that dice.
There's one that I threw in there that's
um,
uh,
what did I call that one?
It's,
Oh,
it's titled the Christian
fundamentalist.
I would love to introduce you to my pet
King Cobra.
And there's actually a reason for that
because the in the gospels and there's
the story of Jesus telling you that if
you really have faith in him,
if you are a pedestrian,
Ndi fade and all of that,
you could take boys on snakes,
could our soul to you and bite you and
you'll be totally fine.
And I was like,
wow,
you know,
if that's what Jesus is seen and
different diseases,
what you guys believe,
Hey,
let me.
But in Gavin the snakes that savvy to
try and it's like one of two things are
going on.
Either you know that the stuff you
believe in is crap and you don't really
believe it or you know that you are.
That there are no good Christians
because.
Sorry,
that's not the way it works today.
I don't care how much faith you have.
It's like nobody can survive taking the
boys on our staff,
on our or your Alameda deadline in the
Bible is crap.
And he was in,
you know,
it was booting there by somebody else,
but he's not real.
In which case it doesn't exactly say
great things about the reliability of
the whole thing,
but it's like there's no getting out of
it.
It's like,
how do you get out of that?
You don't know.
I had a conversation with a guy recently
there was telling me that there are
people that believe so much that they
can drink poison and not die.
And I was like,
oh man,
what a crazy conversation we're having
here.
I doubt that,
you know,
have you seen,
this is not scientific.
This is not something that's been proven
by studies.
Like does someone say that they
absolutely believe if someone can take
poison and not die because their belief
in themselves,
there's only one way to tell homie
that's my take that poison.
Like,
Hey,
I'm not saying he's not through.
Let's try convinced me aim.
If you're right,
you'll have $0
people following and you'll be the
greatest asset to Christianity ever
because you made a millions converts and
they're actually to tell the defendant.
Some of these guys really are serious
about it.
There have been a bunch of people were
particularly in a,
um,
in a lot of Carolinas,
Tennessee,
a few places where there was this
tradition of a snake handlers that they
would,
uh,
you know,
let poisonous snakes by them and you
know,
quite a few of these guys died,
miserable dads and then some of them are
boys and wasn't that much,
so they managed to survive and all of
that up.
I'm like,
Damn,
really?
Jesus Christ,
what a way to go,
uh,
butts.
But I love it when you ask things like
that.
I'm like,
Hey,
I'm not telling you it's crap.
I'm not saying he's not through.
It's there,
let's test it.
That just led just that way.
People need something,
man.
They're always going to need something
whether they're going to need,
you know,
liberalism,
conservativism,
he did a path.
They need someone that just chop out the
brush for them and point them in the
right direction.
Whether it's Christianity,
whether it's
atheism.
I've met atheists that might as well
have been religious stuff that they're
just,
they're so anti religion that there,
it's a,
it's a religion in and of itself.
I had a chapter that I was supposed to
go in the book that was basically saying
that eight k stand hardcore
fundamentalist are doing separated at
birth because they are both based on
certainty on how the universe works and
all of that,
but then my publisher decided,
did you already are offending people,
have 7 million different religions you
want to have.
We want to sell some books about us
keeping the eight.
This chapter,
let's when they both have in common is
they would all shit their pants if they
saw an alien that I think everybody
that's the trump card is the aliens.
If a real fucking alien battleship,
like all these stupid movies that keep
coming out,
there's another stupid movie coming out
where it comes out of the ocean and then
they fucking go to or the American
military to shoot cannons at this
fucking crazy robot monstrosity thing
that pops out of the ocean.
Damn,
I missed the jewel of cinematography.
It's not out yet.
It's coming think in March,
but whatever it is,
it's like is a never ending theme.
Right?
There's never anything with someone way
smarter than us coming down and just
fucking our world up hurling missiles
through buildings.
Buildings explode.
It's like a standard vision of a Chinese
adult when nobody could do are all these
weird stuff going on with my body and
nobody could figure it out.
This guy was amazing.
He just makes me like that,
but the last time I saw him he's found a
half hour telling me about there is our
mother sheeps calming at the end of the
of 2012 and who knows whether they are
nice or not.
He was really good even though I was
like,
what if he's right?
Seriously,
seriously was when old motherfuckers
with their degrees and in suit and tie
all the top doctors from Kaiser and all
of that.
Couldn't figure anything out for me.
Him these crazy eyes and do it in the
use.
Acupuncture,
acupuncture he gave me.
RBC was.
I mean I was something like,
I'm going to throw anything,
but the dude is literally in this hole
in the wall.
He's wedding five watches.
I don't ask why or anything.
That's where all his baby mama was
standing all over the world,
so like that.
But what do I have to lose at this point
and why?
The guy fixed it.
He told me her back.
I could puncture,
we'll fix your back and then you have an
infection that will give you the herbs
and you'll be fine.
Well,
infection.
What kind of infection?
Yeah,
no idea.
But he was like,
this stuff will magically,
whatever it is,
we'll get rid of it real up.
Sure enough because I mean they did at
Geyser.
I dad like seven gazillion tests than
from Mris to rx tool evidencing you name
it.
They couldn't figure out any stress
related for sure.
I mean,
but stress can cause real stuff.
Not just um,
psychosomatic psychosomatics really fuck
you up in specific ways.
So I mean,
yeah,
he was thrusted related,
embodied,
like who knows specifically what it is,
nobody figure it out.
And then the crazy Chinese guy safe me
was telling me about Ufo was the whole
time.
And that's what I mean about while he
was,
while he was fixing it,
he telling you about your phone still
worked up,
so thought that.
So that's almost like eliminating the
placebo effect.
Like,
this guy's fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Be talking to me about.
You have those people love the idea of
Ufo.
It's a fucking amazing idea for them.
It's fine.
You know,
it's so exciting.
I know that they're out there and that
they're watching and they're coming in,
they're going to need to know what they
are.
Your friends or their key Leo.
Yeah.
I just,
I,
um,
I don't,
I'm not saying that they're not real.
Just like,
I'm not saying that there's not really a
guy in the clouds.
It's just I've not seen anything.
Anything compelling.
It's possible.
Sure.
I mean,
I leave it open that it would come,
but I'm not seeing anything compelling,
you know,
even the birth of a child.
That's not what we're talking about.
We're talking about Ufo as you fuckhead
just tuned out and tune back in.
Took my words completely out of context,
how dare you.
But if the aliens did land,
that would be.
That'd be the end of everything.
If there was something way smarter than
us,
we would just have to give up.
Right?
We would have to.
We would,
we would be so stunned.
That's when cults were just rise up.
That's that.
That would be a dark moment.
If it's a real alien culture did come
here for another planet,
you know,
people would really get frantic.
That's when people would really like
some stock stock up on food and 50
caliber guns and what?
That's good.
Either way,
you know,
if you are dealing with something that's
so much more powerful,
so much so it's like you think it's
possible for a society to get smart
enough to be able to travel through
space and,
and go and fuck with other people or
another planet.
I mean,
look at the stuff we do today.
If somebody asked you if he was possible
50 or so ago,
it looks like magic.
I of this stuff.
But we're always like one fuck up away
from blowing each other sky high.
That one doesn't rule.
The other doesn't overlap with the
other.
You know,
the fact that you can be incredibly
smart and come up with all these awesome
stuff doesn't mean you are wise enough
to deal with data and not fuck ever seen
God,
which is humanity right there.
That is humanity in a nutshell.
Yeah.
It would be such a fucking shame if we
library of Alexandria,
this whole thing.
It just went boom.
Just torch this whole civilization.
And we had to really start from scratch.
Yeah.
And I would see as little in my day I
think,
well that is the one sort of.
I'm not,
I don't want to say justification,
but the one sort of argument for having
one powerful military that dominates the
rest of the world as I go to is that by
doing that,
at least they keep everybody else from
blowing everything up.
Keep keep your military from growing to
the point where you were able to make
the same decisions that we can make.
We don't want that.
Yeah.
A,
there's an argument and then I guess if
you look at the statistics,
like what people are like,
you know,
what the potential for people to behave
as like,
yeah,
I'm not a big fan of the US government,
but when I compare it to a lot of,
there are a bunch of places and
governments that I would like about
turning.
There are many others.
I'm like,
Jesus Christ giving me George Bush
again,
you know,
just give me the worse could happen.
US ever.
And the still I like it better than the
Taliban,
you know?
Yeah,
no kidding,
right?
Isn't it funny,
you know,
but it's amazing the spectrum of
different sorts of regimes that exist at
the same time like what's going on right
now in Syria and while you know the
Americas are complaining about the
National Defense Authorization Act,
which takes away a lot of civil
liberties,
so nothing compared to what the fuck is
going on in the Middle East and the
riots of Arabs Arab spring and what's
going on right now in Egypt and the,
the power void in Iraq.
You know,
there's parts of the world right now
that are fa a fucked up a lot,
a lot,
a lot.
I think we as Americans can barely even
wrap our heads around that.
It doesn't even seem real,
of course,
because unless you leave it,
what the hell?
Yeah.
That's something you see on tv for 30
seconds.
That doesn't mean shit.
That's like the one argument for a
powerful military right there.
Fucking press world,
you know,
and um,
people always say that I've,
I've been accused of being a liberal.
I've been accused of being anti
military,
which I'm absolutely not.
I'm always anti the people that are
pointing the military in certain
directions.
Yeah,
that's what I'm anti.
Yeah.
Anti a lot of,
a lot of the people's decisions at the
very top of the heap.
But as far as like having a military,
yeah.
You better fucking better.
It is.
It's the rest of the world does.
Yeah.
It's good to have a military.
It's very good to keep an eye on all
these crazy assholes all over the world
too because yeah,
there's people.
That's the thing.
People then at state good overlap with
the every single about the commentary is
amazing and wonderful and then when they
find out that it's not all amazing and
wonderful that some bad shit happened,
they go to the extreme opposite and it's
like every scene that some Eddy County
is horrible,
terrible,
and the US is responsible for every
scene that's evil in the world.
It's like,
no,
that's not the more complicated than
that.
It's very complicated.
It's very quickly.
The economy in and of itself is very
complicated and a lot of laws that are
in place are very complicated and one of
the reasons why they're in places
because getting rid of laws gets rid of
jobs.
We're police officers don't like that.
That's one of the big problems with drug
enforcement.
You know,
drug enforcement as a,
as a business,
you know the Drug Enforcement Agency,
it's a business drug and forcing is a
business that you're spending money,
jobs are created.
This is how ridiculous it gets.
In Florida,
they had people that were pretending to
be high school students are,
you know the story.
I read it.
I think I tweeted it recently and I mean
there's been more than one case of
these.
One of them,
they arrested 28 kids and another one,
this woman was hot and she was 25 and
she was flirting with 15 year old boys.
They became facebook friends.
They were texting each other and she was
flirting with him,
asking him to get her weed so he got her
weed.
This poor kid is poor love,
smitten kid.
Got Her weed and he said he didn't even
want to take money for it.
He said it was a gift.
She couldn't give him money and then
they arrest him and now they're going to
charge him with fucking,
you know,
a potential nine years in jail or
something crazy.
You know,
what,
what an asshole thing to do,
what a crazy ridiculous asshole thing to
do.
And that goes back to that point is
like,
why the fuck do people feel the need to
tell other people how to live?
You don't like it.
That's what we're talking about.
It's a business that there's a job.
There's jobs that were created in that
sting,
you know,
they created this thing,
they went into high school and they got
kids to sell them weed and they did it
in such a sneaky fucked up way.
The fact that a 25 year old woman could
ever have a position where she talks a
boy thing and have that boy responsible
for it.
Yeah,
dude,
a boy and a 15 year old boy has no idea
what the fuck is going on.
He just sees tents and skin and lips and
she's touching his hand and his dick is
hard and he can't even believe she's
talking to him.
He can't even believe she's talking to
him.
I'll get you weed.
I'll get you whatever the fuck you want.
He can't believe she's so hot.
She looks like a woman because she has a
moment that fucking bitches.
Totally cheating.
She's not 15.
She's not a fellow high school student.
She's a 25 year old cop,
right?
Assholes.
How ridiculous.
So that's the thing.
It's like I got it.
There are jobs in that fight.
I get it,
but unfortunately it's possible to
figure out a way to like they don't want
to get shot busting on a meth lab.
He's in there.
Labs are hard to break into.
Isn't there enough real estate to going
on where people could work to solve real
problems going on?
Yeah.
You would hope you would hope,
but you know,
I don't.
I don't think it's that logical.
I think it's a money grab and I think
people go where the money is and there
is money right now in enforcing their
current drug laws.
There's a lot of jobs that would be lost
if we just said,
right.
Pot's legal,
sorry.
You know how many fucking people are
going to be out of jobs?
That's a,
that's a real issue,
you know,
and it's something that should be
corrected to.
There should be a bill that addresses
that as well and says,
listen,
we're going to replace these drug
enforcement jobs with jobs where they're
doing,
you know,
something more,
more,
more helpful,
you know,
whatever the fuck it is.
Border Security,
Something.
Something that makes more sense.
Board is courteous,
terrible example,
sure.
Put them in torpedoes or submarines
rather get to patrol the ocean.
These are just,
these aren't really well thought out
ideas,
but if you were trying to come up with a
good bill,
a good bill would be make marijuana
legal,
make it a readily available and sellable
and then take the jobs will be lost and
Drug Enforcement and put them into
something positive.
So whatever it could be forestry,
whatever,
whatever jobs.
But then the issue would be those people
wouldn't be qualified for those jobs.
So how,
how do those people benefit from it are
those people are just going to be shit
out of luck?
Not over the whole new career.
Not only jobs that require you to,
you know,
study for 20 years,
I'm sure it could be a period of
training where they still get money as
they are getting trained for the viewer
in Drug Enforcement for like 25 years,
which a lot of guys are right.
And then you know,
all of the sudden it's banished,
kinda sucks for them and that's not
their fault.
It's not your fault when you a young cop
and you think that this is a.
well,
it's the law,
it's what it is,
but it is.
It's almost not your fault.
You're,
you're,
you're suckered into doing something
that's actually a moral.
It just seems like it's okay because
it's behind the wall,
have something written down on paper
somewhere,
but the reality of it is it's pretty
fucking a moral.
You know,
when you're,
when you're locking a kid up in a cage
because you caught them with some plants
or some fungus.
That's absolutely an APP.
It's reprehensible and everyone knows
that inherently they know it inside and
if you don't,
you're fooling yourself.
It's really that simple.
It's just,
it's just,
it's amazing that we still have to have
these conversations and not only that we
can do because if you look at the
political scene,
nobody,
not Republicans,
not Democrats.
I mean not.
Nobody was a shot at winning,
let's put it that way.
I would even bring up these topics
because it's political suicide,
you know,
he's like,
you are soft on their ad.
You really want the roads to be shooting
anyway.
No,
it's like the problem is those dangerous
drugs,
man,
those problems,
those drugs that fucking socked and we
need to like really get it out there to
kids like don't fuck with heroin.
I don't fuck with math,
don't fuck with all these dangerous
ones.
You know,
there's a lot of debt.
And if,
if things were legal,
like if cocaine was legal,
you would actually buy real cocaine.
He would go to a pharmacy or whatever
the fuck you would buy it if it was
legal and goodbye real cocaine,
you know,
you're not getting real cocaine.
Now you're getting real cocaine that
joey has bought and chopped up and you,
you know what I mean?
Who knows what you're getting of Myrica
Matt,
uh,
Albert Hoffman,
the guy who will create the less day.
And one of the things that you
established me was,
uh,
you know,
most of the stuff that goes for lsd
around the word is not a name because
the stuff that,
the way I make,
it uses certain compounds that are so
rare that there's no way that he could
support such mantra production.
They're just teasing them up over that
stuff.
Wow.
You say whatever they sell out there,
it's.
I have no idea what the holidays,
but he's served on these now my stuff
and he argue a dang.
Who knows?
Maybe it's through a window,
but he argued at ea staff would give you
kind of hold the benefits of lsd without
all the crap from St Louis.
And I'm so treat us to lsd though,
is still giving you the same benefits as
the stuff that he produces was just
wasn't as taxing on the body.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They made that shit illegal too,
too much.
She goes,
actually you see these guys like a
Suisse cammies to sylvere was all doing
very now he's been dead for awhile.
But uh,
he's uh,
and he was originally looking for a cure
for headache.
Like he was working on a headache pill
and he came up with LSD.
That was pretty fun to come up with it
and not even realize it took it
accidentally.
Got It in his skin and it was riding
home on his bike and just tripping his
fucking balls off.
Yeah.
Not knowing what he did,
they had no idea what the dosage was
back then because lsd like the,
the dosage to body ratio has been
compared to an ant demolishing the
empire state building in 30 seconds.
Like literally like that's how powerful
like a little tiny drop of this shit is.
He didn't know that man.
He probably was drinking glasses of it
though.
Acid shots,
shots of acid.
Oh my God.
But I did that.
I met the guy.
He say sat Sunday seem perfectly
coherent and logical steel and all of
that.
So who knows?
Maybe it was right.
There's a different look that those old
guys that have done acid having their
eyes.
It is a different look.
You know,
they,
there's a,
there's a weird thing that you get
sometimes we're talking to one of those
old asset dudes.
You might've seen some shit that's not
available anymore.
You know,
they might have seen some limited
production view of life.
Threw acid that acid in the sixties.
I would've loved to have seen what it
was like,
like the flower child,
children of the San Francisco,
early 19 sixties.
You know,
I watched that a hunter s Thompson
documentary,
a Gonzo the life and times I'm doctor
and it's a fucking fun documentary,
but one of the things that talks about
what's the utopia of the asset culture,
the early 19 sixties and San Francisco
and they show all these people running
around holding hands together,
tripping their balls off,
and it's really interesting,
man.
Like that was a,
that whole fucking part of the world.
It wasn't illegal yet and that whole
part of the world was just blossoming
with all these new ideas and new music
and this new sort of wild psychedelic
culture was all like emanating out of
this one place and they fucking threw
the water on it and squash that shit.
Yeah,
it's amazing if you,
if you just list them to the music alone
and you asked them to what was in the 19
fifties and then you switched to a six
days was like,
what the hell just happened?
He's like,
he's a whole other universe right there
as.
Yeah,
they,
they came up with some fucking
incredible shit and that makes it all
happened.
I mean,
a lot of it all happened in that area of
San Francisco,
you know,
it's a widow.
Was there a moment in time,
man,
where if time travel is impossible,
but time recreationists they ever
figured out a way to to recruit,
like we could just go in and peek that
we know like remember those things that
you had when you were a kid,
the view sliders and it was like a
dinosaur and you would click click and
it will be the next dinosaur.
If there was something you could put on
some goggles and just take a view as to
what life was like in a certain area.
You know,
$5 million years ago,
be like a fucking a security camera on
the wall 100 million years ago in the
jungle and watched dinosaurs rundown
Jack and things.
I wonder if that will be eventually
possible.
I wouldn't it if you.
Maybe you can't have travel back in time
that you can have a view get.
That's where even if they just had some
amazing computer simulation of what had
happened.
I think I'm good with.
Yeah,
what the fuck.
We're lucky,
we're very lucky we were living in
2012.
We would have been dead at any other
time in history where two week we
wouldn't have been able to deal with the
caveman era or the Babylonian Empire or
the Sumerian days when was coming.
That's supposed to take place.
I mean,
it's funny because he actually have to
use us a lot of history,
but then he argues that,
you know,
he makes up a lot of graph of course
history.
Robert e Dot Howard did like what?
What did he use a lot?
If you look at these maps,
they are based on many of the cultures
see nice sort of fantasy wall or dire
based then on cultures that eventually
evolve in a real historical times that
we know of,
but he supposed to predate all this
stuff.
We know.
So he argues that there was Atlantis and
it's super powerful.
It's utilization and that collapsed and
the ward went into this hardcore
barbarianism and then civilizations who
are rising up again and that's when
Conan set scene and then the history we
know of that comes down the road.
So is it so appealing for men?
I mean the guy goes around chopping
people set off,
grabbing all of the most beautiful women
in the land.
I mean,
do I need to go on?
He drinks all the time.
Yeah.
But the,
that era like that,
that the,
that,
not that arrow rather,
but that genre,
the,
the sorcery and the snakes and the
monsters,
he's always fighting and you know,
Conan had the coolest fucking stories.
Like what is it?
I mean literally essentially taps into
them young male fantasy.
Especially the,
as you become older,
you're supposed to.
I'm in my forties,
I'm so drop that,
you know,
I'm not supposed to be like into like
the next cone and movie.
Like someone get it right.
Like that's ridiculous.
I'm a father and as a grown man and I'm
in the Conan,
the barbarian cares,
it becomes,
there was,
it's a,
it is,
it taps into like a real curse
adolescent childhood sort of fantasy
genre thing in our heads.
I mean,
who doesn't want to.
What was in the movie?
What's the best thing?
Life Corner,
your enemies have been before you hear
the limitations of women.
Is that,
what is the limitation lamp?
I used to say lamination.
You know,
it's funny,
I actually grew up,
I watched Conan a million times in
Italian and so I never really heard it
in,
in English.
And when I heard,
uh,
our note speaking it,
I was like,
oh Jesus,
this is a whole completely different
movie watching kids.
At least that was the original voice.
Like,
Hey,
come here.
No,
it wasn't just these mentally tough guy,
but nothing particular,
no one ever gets it right when they do
like a voiceover,
they hardly ever get it right that time.
Maybe because I at least include that
one first.
I was like,
Oh God,
they English.
Arson sucks.
It's painful.
It really.
So the English version would arnold who
wasn't as good.
How dare you.
Because it makes you laugh.
His voice,
especially when you don't expect it,
because I was used to seeing Conan
speaking like a regular human being and
I'm saying he might have went with a,
could accent his accent.
Listen to you,
but my accent is great.
Will your accent has a certain amount of
classical flair to it?
The Italian accent.
It's go to the garden.
A role to the tongue.
Say Right.
Welcome to the olive garden.
He's gonna.
Use that for video now.
That's my new ring tone.
Fluxion weird.
A love affair with the olive garden.
It's his religion.
He didn't go with Judaism.
Somebody tweeted me yesterday that I was
supposed to tell him that I saw him at
the olive garden.
Weird,
stupid running joke.
It will go on forever too.
He will not let it go,
but the strangest thing you've ever
seen.
Picking up people to 18 and stuff.
I wanted to mention.
Your fans are fucking awesome.
I've never been around people who are
like.
After the first podcast I got to meet
different people on facebook now I
started at twitter and stuff and you
know every single person I've run into
as been really smart,
really nice,
super polite,
but you check out their pages and they
are all live like really interesting
people.
We are funny man.
So I was like,
man,
I'm happy that there are people like
that out there,
you know,
I think if you
that sort of that sort of a show,
you know,
you put all that kind of um,
that kind of a vibe and have people like
you come on the show and you know,
other people that have had that people
have really reacted to like Graham
Hancock and I got this Sam Harris
County.
It's coming on soon and you know,
having like really intelligent,
interesting people on the show it and,
and,
and putting out,
do you know,
your own,
your personal philosophy on things.
You know,
so people just fucking be nice to
people.
Stop being content to each other.
Everybody can be cool.
Everybody should be generous.
Like surrounding yourself with a bunch
of people that you really like and
don't,
don't tolerate any bullshit and
negativity from removed that shit from
your life.
Remove that shift from what you're doing
for a living.
Push yourself in the direction that you
actually want to go in.
And you know,
when you put that out there,
people respond to it and they start.
It starts to become a part of their
vibration,
starts to become a part of who they are
as a person.
You know,
and I think that's what's happened.
We have like this crazy group of people
that are super cool,
you know,
I mean,
it's,
I'm not delusional about this.
It sounds completely ridiculous that I
would even say,
well,
there's a reason why my crowd's cool,
but if you go to my shows,
the waitresses are always saying that,
that he was so nice and that they're so.
They're so generous.
I think it's just,
you put that out there,
man.
I think it's good for all of us,
Like I didn't figure this out all on my
own.
I had to meet a bunch of people that
started behaving like this.
I had to meet people that had their shit
together,
that impressed me,
that we're nice and were positive and
that impacted me.
And I learned from the way they behaved.
You know,
I think,
I think we're all doing that for each
other and these conversations and you
know,
these,
these subjects that we're having these
know these subjects are,
you know,
it's unusual that you would have,
someone who knows as much religion in
your life to as you do to sit down with
and,
and go over this kind of stuff.
Right.
There's not a lot of opportunities that
people have to,
to a lot of big group of cool people.
It's one of the best things about this
podcast.
It makes me happy because,
you know,
I'm a judgmental little bastard so I see
a lot of people where I'm like,
Eh,
I don't like you so much.
And all of that.
So for me to say,
Jesus,
I'm blown away by the quality of people
that are running into after that nurse
just I'm not a wine was always like,
you know,
everything goody goody evidencing is
great and one and fire from Athens.
So I was really mad.
I,
it's hard to keep track of so many good
conversation with some people that will
touch base with me after that.
I was really,
really impressed with it,
so that's awesome,
man.
Yeah.
Like I said,
I think you can put that out there man,
but then out there it's what you're
going to get back.
You know,
when you,
when you put out there in the universe.
It sounds completely corny and hippie
and ridiculous,
but I think the EU,
we all,
we,
we all can do with like sort of
absorbing a good community.
We all could do that at the Internet and
I think that's one of the big powers
that the Internet gives us is it gives
us the ability to form communities.
It gives us the ability to choose who
you associate with and,
and you know,
and connect to people in a way that it's
never really been possible before
because that's the funny thing.
You probably get the message from the
guy in Iceland somewhere where he's like
the weird guy in the village and
everybody else is looking at him like,
what's your problem?
And now he has a chance to realize shit
that are other people out there.
You can see the water the way I do and
the message board and on twitter,
and there's always people from people
from Norway and Sweden and Iceland and
all throughout Europe and all
throughout.
I've have people that post from China,
from islands,
you know,
it's amazing.
You know,
it's uh,
the,
the idea of twitter,
you know,
the idea of,
anybody from anywhere in the world.
It's like sinking up through this thing
and then there's going to be something
after that it was going to be,
they're going to figure out some next
step after twitter where things are
going to get really strange.
I hope for a while they come back,
their name considerably just took me
forever to get on twitter because it was
like really do I want to get something
called with dirt and it's like Jesus
Christ to have some self respect there.
Come on,
you know,
it sounds ridiculous.
They should have called the corner and
then I would have to respect that.
It's.
That would've been cool.
Today's episode is called Conan.
Yeah,
exactly.
We got a little silly today with Colin
and I think we might have over Conan,
Conan enthusiast get together.
Sparks fly.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
You ever read any Robert e Dot Howard
and you were a boy?
Uh,
I read the comic.
I didn't read the books or anything,
man.
You gotta you gotta get the books to
this day.
You'll enjoy it if you're not going to
read a book.
Why am I even saying that to you?
When was the last time you read a book?
I'm actually recently,
it started to re reading the Steve Jobs
books,
but I never finished.
You like to read biographies?
You read like Steve Martin's,
right?
Oh yeah.
Also what is a,
what did it say?
Well,
Steve Jobs was he do shit.
I didn't finish it.
I like,
it was just kind of going through his,
his,
you know,
everything.
So is stuff I already knew stuff for the
most part,
but there's a guy,
he sort of formed a little cult,
our cult of technology and fucking
slick.
I got Gazal Fuck fanboy I used to.
I was a fucking fat boy.
Did you hear about the Steve Jobs and
watch his little speeches and shit?
We would bring out new laptops.
So dumb.
Did you go with the controversy about
the Steve Jobs Doll?
No,
I haven't.
There's this steve jobs doll that was
made and I think China and it looks so
realistic and it comes with like all
these like little things like,
hey,
this is for presentation so you can kind
of play doll with them.
But apple was like a cease and desist
and so now it's like calling it a steve
jobs doll.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I'll show you a picture.
It's scary.
It's really scary because it looks just
like them.
What if Steve Jobs dolls became the new
crucifix?
People who are fucking crucifix come
about.
How did they.
Well,
how do they start carrying around the
one thing that killed Jesus.
That's what an unlikely choice.
Speaking of which can you imagine?
Because up until not that long before,
one of the choice for more of that
penalty was as a people being bailed out
budget,
but not always the case.
People would have hanging out there with
bikes to get to a guy sas and that.
That would be good.
So,
uh,
the originator or the original story
that draco was based on Vlad the impaler
Baylor.
Yes.
He used to eat his lunch and they,
there's photos of him.
Well,
not photos of them.
Obviously the drawings rather have him
sitting at a banquet table while these
people are on spikes writhing around
him.
And that's how you eat his dinner,
pick it up.
[inaudible],
see Cedar liquidity badges.
Somebody thinking,
let me figure out and I can shop.
And these giant Paula somebody says,
but missing all the internal organs.
So I don't kill them.
And then they get slowly.
It's like,
oh my God,
think of that horrible man.
Just what a terrible way to die.
Jesus Christ.
It's hard to even wrap your head on.
And it took a long time for those people
that die.
It took a long time.
That was the goal.
She's fucking.
Yeah.
And apparently the vlad the impaler
story was a guy,
he was particularly ruthless.
And one of the things,
because he was out numbered.
So he,
uh,
set up a lot of these bodies outside the
perimeter of his town just to scare the
fuck anybody would come near and it was
more like he was,
he was like back up against the wall and
had to take some crazy chances.
Right.
And yeah,
I mean he became started right into it.
Yeah.
You imagine that man,
they,
they make a fucking monster movie about
you hundreds of years after you're dead.
What it impact you had.
Yeah.
That's when you know you're bad ass
crazy asshole.
Yeah.
Seriously.
But yeah.
Can you imagine if that wasn't instead
of punishment in Jesus' times.
Now Christians today are the dirt and
just,
you know,
all themselves and stuff.
You'll just me,
me,
me make mimic the pole up the,
that would be the thing you would do
instead of the cross.
Oh my God.
People Enter Church Avenue.
Oh,
could you imagine?
Oh that be so ridiculous.
I mean,
it's just as ridiculous as nailing
yourself to the fucking car.
I mean,
what do you do when you're making the
points of the cross the cross?
I mean,
it's such a bizarre symbol.
Lenny Bruce said it best,
he's like,
100 years from now.
It's like people walking around with the
electric chairs around their neck and
fucked up the junk.
I forgot how he said it.
I forget.
I forget exact wording.
And then Bill Hicks had another one.
It's like a really variation on that
joke.
He said it was like a Jackie Onassis and
walking up to her whether with a rifle
pendant on thinking about John,
you know,
really kind of on the same job,
but it really is true.
They killed him on that thing and people
carried around.
How'd that tradition gets started?
Fuck.
Oh,
do much way to our different.
I don't remember.
You don't remember?
You don't remember how that tradition
got started?
How they started mailing?
No.
And they link people to the cross.
You got high before the show didn't you
know?
We got a little too high in and out.
It's rocket fuel son.
That's high grade.
It's not.
It's problematic.
It's a wave.
Sometimes you know,
it crushes you onto it and then you got
to get back up on your board.
Happy.
Anyway.
So it doesn't really matter some moments
I'm on and that makes sense,
like failing similarity in as long as
you're happy,
I'm happy.
But.
So how did they,
uh,
W,
why do people start carrying around the
cross?
It was one off.
Does a punishments like impaling people.
The idea was how can we make you
suffered reward in a very public way
where people go by and they will see you
slowly dying there for three days and
uh,
it goes back to this desire of rulers in
17 states and the Roman sweater,
perfect example of these guys,
but they weren't the only ones doing
that tool.
Got into it because he was a way to make
a statement which is don't fuck with us
because if you ever even think of
rebelling against us,
this is what's going to happen to you.
And every time you go down the street
you see somebody there and think about
you being there.
You might want to think about that plan.
Offer a value on that.
You how often when they crucifying
people,
and I mean you don't have to do it that
often to have an impact on people.
I don't think you need to see that many
people crucified for it to stay in your
head,
but,
but you had cases like when the spiral
psychosis,
where after the rebellion they grabbed
like thousands of slaves and nailed them
one every so many hundred feet between
Naples and Rome.
That's a long fucking high and the
entire way people on Colossus or oh my
God,
Holy Shit.
It's hard.
Hardcore.
That is terrifying.
And now how the fuck do people go from
that to wearing one around your chain
diamonds?
How did she go from one P diddy?
You know,
big ass bling,
bling crosses.
So Jesus is up.
That's what I love about 80 scrape
shirts.
You know,
like Jesus don't like him,
but the guy was very hardcore about
economics.
You know,
one of the things he says is a easier
for a camel to go through the eye of a
needle than for a rich man to get into
heaven.
Wow.
Karl Marx doesn't go that far.
You know what I mean,
it's like easier for a camel to go
through the eye of a needle than for a
rich man to get into heaven.
God Damn Jesus was dropping some poor
man's science.
So,
I mean he is probably a bit in that.
It's probably totally a bit in the
crosses.
So explain to me again,
I'm going to write this down.
Where did the crosses,
how far did they last from old people?
Piss Shit.
He wasn't Jewish.
Time is definitely money was emerged as
well,
I want to say started in Burger but,
but the um,
the people that were a pinned off in the
cross,
the,
you know,
the road that you were talking about,
there was 1000.
How many feet was it where people were
on the cross?
He was between Naples and Rome.
And how far as the economic center later
in April.
So he's a good chunk of.
It's definitely over a hundred miles I
can remember.
So for 100 miles.
Yeah.
Whoa,
whoa.
I forgot how many hundred miles people
were strung up on crosses.
Well,
they add some thousands of,
but he's a nurse for Lilian defeating
spartacus.
They had leaked already thousands of
them and so they decided to execute them
all by sticking demo long colossus
between Rome and Naples where now,
where the whole thing went down and um,
make a very public statement about four
others.
Leave thinking about labels in the room.
That is Nancy.
Yeah,
Naples is actually,
it's more than that.
It's because he's not a wire to do that,
uh,
at the Emmy's wherein,
you know,
big ass fucking platinum cross with some
Nice Diane was on and maybe white gold
and that's awesome.
Exactly.
You get the reach thing to do it without
you,
that rich people will know.
It's like,
what the hell is or the big cross
tattoo.
That's another one,
right?
It's the same.
I mean,
I get it,
I get what you're trying to do,
but if you've really thought about what,
what the cross was used for Jesus Christ
now I don't think anybody knows that.
I think very few people knew that there
was a time in history where people were
strung up on crosses for over a hundred
miles.
I mean,
how many actual total humans was that I
think has about $5,000,
if I remember correctly.
He wasn't in the thousands,
that's for sure.
I want to say five.
Oh yeah.
But I mean that's,
you know,
that's one of the thing in enrollment
times they add gazillions,
laves and yet hardly ever any rebellion.
Well,
you know why?
Because when they do it,
they got strung up on cross this for
hundreds of miles and have their power
lines.
They were replaced with power lines.
The same visual of these creepy pap,
you know the history.
It's power lines are not as creepy as
crosses brown.
Well,
no,
I mean like,
like those old ones,
like those old ones where there's like a
million wires all attached to this giant
one.
Like I have one in the back of my house.
I just look at it every day.
I'm like,
oh,
that's not good.
Yeah.
What about those?
You ever drive like the certain towns
and they have these giant fucking
enormous ones that they hum when you
pass by them and they feed,
you know like towns are like miles and
miles away.
Those are,
they can't.
It can't be good next to that right now.
That's got to be fucking with your
system somehow or some form.
Yeah.
Is it ever proven that.
I don't know,
but there's a lot of houses even in
Burbank because burbank uses still uses
those power lines and there's a
humongous ones and their houses below it
and you just kinda feel eerie.
It feels eerie being around that area
because there's just humming above.
You like this humongous pool.
There's different ones like you know,
there's certain areas like really rural
areas where your past by big fucking
giant ones.
I know I don't understand much about the
science behind providing electricity to
cities,
but you know,
there's obviously a lot of,
there's a lot of energy going through
those goddamn things.
If your house is just sitting there,
director of the thing is just right
above you.
Is that fucking with some things that
you can't see?
I think so.
You think so?
That shouldn't be.
Did you google this?
I'm just talking about what would I
Google power lines.
Cancer.
It probably.
Yeah.
Cancer's always.
We look for it,
right?
Yeah,
but yeah,
that's the scene today that nobody
knows.
It's like,
hm,
we have gazillions causes cancer about
we don't know why.
There are many,
many,
many things in our environment that are
fucked up from the stuff we eat to this
stuff,
our land to all sorts of things that we
don't really know what to what degree
they were do in Oakland three builds,
but
the fact that that Msg is even allowed
to be used today.
Oh,
you mean just drives me crazy delicious
though,
Huh?
It is,
but it's so unnecessary.
It was a bad for you or something.
It's proven to give you cancer
restaurants.
Restaurants use it all the fucking time
though.
They don't tell you really.
That's kind of like,
hey,
thanks.
You might want to say,
hey,
there's something in here that might
cause cancer.
If this guy's telling me this why I
smoke cigarettes,
because the Chinese film ain't going to
kill you bro.
Unless you're driving through all day,
every day,
that monosodium glutamate,
who do you know that we had a funeral
for your friend because Montessori,
but man was living large who nobody had
this Chinese food addiction.
He just could not kick.
Yeah,
but who knows though.
Definitely known people who have died of
cancer that just
just not linked linkedin.
MSG,
but how do they know that it is?
It causes cancer in rats or something
like that.
It's just proven.
Yeah.
We're not rats.
I think we can.
Rats can eat some shit that we can eat.
No,
we shouldn't.
We shouldn't really go by that.
Yeah.
I'm sure I missed you.
Is terrible for you.
I think it's like a.
it's just a flavor enhancer,
right?
Isn't like accent or something like
that.
Just a couple of different brand names
of it.
I don't know because I worked at a
restaurant when I was a kid.
Worked in like a Newport creamery,
which is like a hamburger place.
I think we had this power line cancer
that can't get a fucking straight
answer.
Everybody wants to make you read things.
Just answering me bitch.
In India,
because of a study of 134 people with
stomach cancer who were avid consumers
of which food can contain msg.
The federate fetter ration of hotel and
restaurant owners in eastern India has
asked its members to refrain from using
msg.
There's like a website called
[inaudible] dot org,
backslash cancer dot htm.
And it's just all these reports of like
where MSG is,
like,
no,
it's seriously not.
Why are we serving this?
Where are we allowed to do this
deep?
But you do you.
Are you concerned with it for real?
Well,
I,
I don't think that's necessary.
Here's the,
here's the reason why there's a really
good Thai place that's in Hollywood.
Uh,
it,
they,
I don't want to say the place,
but palms all right.
But it.
But they use MSG and then I had it once
with meg and then the next time I
returned,
I'm just like looking at the menu going,
Jesus Christ,
they put Msg in their food and they have
it right here on the menu that they,
they just like,
hey,
by the way,
we use MSG.
So I go,
can I have no MSG?
And they were like,
oh yeah,
sure,
no problem.
And so I got the same shit I got last
time.
It tasted exactly the same.
It was delicious.
It was amazing.
It wasn't like like,
Oh wow,
there's definitely at night,
maybe every government man,
we're really trying to kill people,
but giving them memos,
chip set or a little allowing it.
That's just weird that that's not a big.
I'm going to google.
Is MSG good for you?
What if it turns out it's good for you
and maybe they told you that.
Sure.
No problem.
No MSG on this one.
The white guy get him the same shit.
You didn't die.
Yeah,
I gotta take a chance by giving you a
superior product but cutting it out.
Yup.
Good.
Shut up.
Eat it.
Um,
I don't know man.
Is it,
is it really that bad for you?
Yeah,
Msg is good for you.
Okay.
I'm reading something is good for you.
An article on Forbes magazine argues at
Msg,
monosodium glutamate,
uh,
may actually be good for the world.
What?
Okay.
Hold on.
Since the onion daily,
you asked the US health nuts avoided
like the plague,
but many parts of Asia.
It sits on the table along with salt and
pepper to enhance the flavor of meals,
leading expert in Msg,
senior scientist company named Blah
Blah,
blah.
Insist that the definitive link between
MSG and headaches has yet to be proven.
Furthermore,
his own research has shown that the
hospital's patients,
hospital,
patients who have lost their appetite
more likely eat their meals.
When sprinkled with MSG.
This he postulates could help elderly
and sick people improve their appetites,
get nutrition they need and live longer
or smoke weed.
Smoking weed would do better than Msj.
Maybe smoking weed.
MSG together is the mother fucker put
some mock poop on that shit.
Well,
I remember it being a big deal.
I remember people were always saying
avoid msg.
Like it became a big deal.
I kind of nowhere,
right.
It was something that people.
It's like right on kind of.
I think like even one day they're like,
oh shit,
you know,
there was this news
report saying that Msg is bad for you
and then I'd Kinda blew up like radon
did.
How did people get like wacky rules as
to like what you can and can't eat and
like biblical days,
like the cloven hoof thing,
it's pork.
What does that even make sense?
It's probably,
there are certain,
you know,
animals that are freaking dirty that are
more likely to carry diseases.
People do.
You lead them and just freaking
diseases.
Steel gets battered around.
So let just say that God said you
shouldn't eat that were done with it,
like chicken little sis and shit like
that.
So I mean,
I'm sure it boiled down to reality,
factual things that people said,
you know what,
we need to make a hardcoded rule because
otherwise people don't respect it.
So let's make it that God said so and
you know,
let's have everybody stick to it.
And then of course then they stopped
making sense when hundreds of years
later,
thousands of theater slate their article
Nisha and Saturday for.
And so they no longer are,
you know,
the animals could be cleaner
conditionals or whatever,
but then the rules sticks around.
Some of them are really nuts,
you know,
like at a certain point in time,
it's not,
it isn't based on health anymore.
It's just based on this strange
tradition.
Yeah,
there's no.
And that you're guilty if you eat like
the pig and the swine.
Like that's the big thing about Muslims.
I don't eat swine.
Right.
You know,
they'll tell you that like,
I remember that was like a cool thing
for rappers to say.
Like back in the nineties,
they don't eat swine.
You know what,
you don't eat swine.
Why not?
It's delicious.
You asshole.
Crazy.
You don't eat bacon or your heart
because you don't eat bacon.
You know,
it's just the idea that your religion to
keep you from Bacon,
just that's all you need to know.
They're not looking out for you.
They keep you.
Keep you from barbecue pork as well.
We'll get the fuck outta here.
Your religion keeps you from spare ribs.
They're assholes.
They must be assholes.
If you go to Dr Holly [inaudible] in
Venice and have the spare ribs and tell
me that that's not heavenly,
that's not a gift of God.
There's a reason God made those ribs
tastes so God damn good.
Right?
I am done with your religion.
How did you approach it?
Is like if a religion doesn't electric,
did you about Baker?
It was awesome.
After you.
Religion doesn't let you eat vegan.
They're not looking out for you there.
They're assholes and I like nuts.
I think that we need to make a new
religion.
Are you willing to put this together?
When you do your new book that you're
going to be able to construct a new
religion.
The working title is create your own
So.
So you're going to pick out all the best
stuff.
That's the idea that have to have any
basis in any previous stories or how can
it be substantiated?
Is there any,
you know like you could use scientology
is what I mean.
It's not based on faith so it's based
on,
you know,
what makes sense to you,
what seems to work and then you know,
try it.
And if it doesn't work,
change it.
But when you're including religions,
are you allowed to include ones that we
know somebody made up mean scientology?
I don't know because I feel like it's
no.
Why is it.
I mean,
why is it any different than what had
happened with that one guy with a dragon
suit that million people died,
but said it was Jesus's brother.
I mean,
eat scientology was sensing that.
Great.
There are a number of people took
extremely seriously.
Then I would say,
sure,
let's play with it.
I would agree with you if I hadn't met
so many actors and I think that that's
why I haven't done so.
It seemed like,
you know,
the world of acting,
it's a hugely popular,
hugely popular amongst successful people
as well.
I think it gives them some sort of a
framework in which to think and behave
in a framework of positivity.
Like,
you know,
everyone's seen that,
uh,
the Tom Cruise in indoctrination video,
I was talking about a car accident.
I keep it.
If you haven't seen it,
folks,
you have to look it up.
If they haven't pulled it from the web,
I hope God,
I hope they haven't pulled it.
Do you think they pulled that cubicle?
The yogi.
The one.
Okay.
Because you're a scientologist these so
fake,
charismatic and it's like,
God,
he's so good at it.
He will be an awesome cult leader.
Oh,
he might have to do it too.
You might have to step in.
You know,
they have to also stepping up because
it's not high enough in the
organization.
No,
no.
I mean literally dude.
And they have to pump him up a little
too mucky thing.
So man,
I think he's so charismatic.
You can get away with it.
Just make sure you keep them on a
podium.
No one's even gonna know.
But then again,
everybody is always seen you on camera.
You can always make him look the alert
if you see this dude is like,
I don't remember.
Maybe he's not that short,
but I thought from what I heard at is
like these probably mostly like hobbits
are not nearly as short as everybody
says.
They probably want to make him seem like
more of a loser because he upsets them.
Probably felt good.
He's doing probably probably.
I mean,
come on when there's a guy like Tom
Cruise has been,
how many goddamn blockbuster movies over
and over and over again,
massive success over and over and over
again.
You're going to look for flaws.
He's gay,
Short.
He's gay.
That's all you ever hear,
Jay short the.
I'm sure there's a name of the lab.
I love you.
I want your life so you must suck for
some other reason.
I wonder how much of an effect
scientology has on his success.
I wonder how much of a.
You know how much of what he pulled off
he would have pulled,
wouldn't have pulled off.
It wasn't deep in the throes of some.
I think you're on your way to convert.
To me,
it sounded cooler and cooler by the sec
on though.
Maybe man,
maybe it's the way to do it.
Maybe we need to all join like a
reasonable cult,
a cult.
It really has his shit together.
I bring up this over and over again to
people think I'm fucking serious.
I want to be clear right now.
No,
I'm not starting a cult for real.
Just fucking around.
All right.
We're just bouncing ideas.
They'll not really going to set up a
compound where people can show up
because if you did,
man,
this is the time of the of the world
where if you did do that,
he said,
listen,
we have 6,000
acres.
It's in Wyoming.
Anybody can sign up.
We do a background check on you.
If you're in build a house.
Come on in,
and we started town.
Did you imagined?
Yeah.
They would shut that down though,
wouldn't you think?
My guess is if we did that,
would you be willing to go and be our
religious advisor?
I've always want to be the.
Keep everybody on the same page.
You know I got to crucify them.
If they don't know you can't do that,
you can't do that.
We're going to try to avoid that.
What we're trying to do is just get a
bunch of people together that we don't
really know that much.
Just sue them out of their,
their,
their current dogma.
Okay.
I like that.
That's all we use.
You know,
so you,
you,
you'd be the guy that under like they,
they can't argue with you.
You're having some areas come up.
Let's have a final match cage between
myself and some areas and see.
We'll get still get the top spot and
some areas.
I know the guy interest.
Interesting.
Sam Harris.
Oh Sam Harris,
Pakistanis.
But some areas.
So I agreed to Harris.
She's going to start his own cult.
It'll break off in its own direction is
called to be smarter than our Colt.
I just thread that.
He started training Jiu Jitsu.
Yeah,
he's there for awhile.
That's not that long.
Okay.
In that case,
taking private lessons.
He's got to come on.
I'm a,
I think it's March 8th is.
He's going to be on and we're going to
talk about.
Take him on whether steel learning
before he gets too good.
At what level is your game?
Where you a purple belt level?
What levels you're gay is weird too
because I enrolled for the longest time,
not in formal classes,
so my way is we are,
because I'm lacking some pieces of the
game that you should learn when you're a
fucking white belt.
But then I don't put my weight.
I don't put enough pressure on top.
I don't do some of the stuff that are
supposed to do that you learn as basics,
but then at the same time I ever like
weird us movements that I can tap.
People were insanely better to me really
is a,
it's kind of weird.
Is A,
I can lose two really 50 people and I
can be three to go to people.
So he's hard to gauge in the same way.
Yeah.
Roughly give or take somewhere around
there somewhere,
somewhere around the purple's range.
But these a is not regular,
you know,
I'm better than a purple belt in some
way and I'm way worse in others.
And so it's,
my game is a little weird that way.
That's interesting.
Like what,
what do you,
what,
what style was it that you learned?
What was like the first time?
Um,
I mean as far as good app thing goes.
Yeah,
no,
I did play.
It was medically,
you know,
grappling with no geese.
So he was,
who did you learn from?
I started out with this guy,
Tim Kartra mail was one of the black
belts from um,
what's his name?
The guy was starting to crop up Sifaka
Kleiber.
Luciana,
I'm Carmela was awesome.
I really like his game.
He was amazing.
Grabbed Blur and uh,
he showed me some stuff and then a lot
of the time I would just add all the way
to people.
Somebody a daryl garage,
they had their Jujitsu guys come over
and we will just throw.
So a lot of it was not the real and
formal learning.
A lot of it was learned by doing and
which has its advantages and
disadvantages,
you know.
So I'm missing a lot of stuff that I
should know.
But then I have others seeing that,
like one thing I used to that are like
blogs,
like vlogs or my game.
He's like,
I catch very dangerous when,
if you're not an asset and the people
you're rolling,
we'd know what they are doing.
You don't have to crank them like crazy.
You know,
you'll catch somebody in some cases when
the guy's not.
That'd be like,
I would just tell him,
I'm like,
dude,
yeah.
You know,
the scariest guys who some are,
Paul says for that reason,
I know he's terrified.
He's seriously scary.
He's terrifying event because he catches
it.
There's mean article or competition.
So if he doesn't do it,
the
guy going to step up and family and.
But he just doesn't give you a chance to
Zap.
You barely have a chance to screaming in
agony.
Yeah.
Tears guys.
Knees apart.
Yeah.
It's terrifying.
Strong too when he jumps on it.
Yeah.
He's a really unusual,
terrifying guy.
Yeah.
A first terrifying guy that rips his
legs apart.
I can't remember a guy who was so
consistent at doing that and you know,
high level mma,
it's really kind of a characteristic.
Um,
that guy,
the Japanese guy one,
he's one of those two guys are like neck
and neck for the best leg locks.
He's terrifying.
He's so good at rapping.
Guys up.
My God,
he's horrifying.
He's got it.
Also an amazing Omoplata submission
called the inventory where you go,
like you have the shoulder lock and then
you grab an esg grip underneath the
guy's face and you lean back and it just
snaps his neck.
It's terrible.
It's a terrible thing because its arm is
twisted and you're pulling his neck
back.
It's nasty.
He's submitted a couple of guys with
that.
He gets it all the time now.
Humanity is one of those guys.
I like his style but it does seem a bit
of a Dick because he willing submission,
like he really is just,
he just three per leg apart and he just,
he's dancing around all I have to finish
guys off.
I mean you kind of have to.
I mean there was one of the reasons why
he's so good and so feared is because he
does that.
Yeah,
that's true.
And then people will stop early that's
dying.
I mean,
I get it,
it's an advantage.
They're going to try to take his
conscience of what his idea is.
They're gonna put his head that's throw,
you know.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's fucking hard game,
man.
Yeah,
it is.
You know,
that's why like when this rampage thing
happened to rampages upset at me,
I'm like,
look,
he's doing a way harder gig than know
what,
what he's doing.
He's a sensitive guy and he's got
literally one of the most difficult jobs
to,
to manage on earth.
You know,
he's going to be irritable about shit.
I'm sorry if I pissed them off.
All I'm trying to do is,
uh,
assess things to martial arts in mixed
martial arts.
Fighting is a got to be one of the
hardest ways to make a living humanly
possible.
It other than being a soldier,
you know,
it's like right up there,
right?
I mean even psychologically going into
the game,
knowing that somebody has spent the last
year training just in order to repeal
thyrex even more effective fashion show,
especially when guys start getting super
emotional talking shit to each other and
they get in each other's faces at the
winds,
you know,
things get really,
really crazy.
I met them when I was.
When I went to Vegas,
I met.
I went because I was a meeting and an
eco tour and so I got one guy with a
gun.
I never met him before and I was really
blown away by the way you see them on tv
the same way you see me in reality and
so column is like the opposite of what
you expect.
Like I kept asking him about fear,
you know,
going into it and being afraid and he
was like a foreign concept to me.
It was like,
I think we have so,
so much as a kid and got over the fear
of portfolio minus the anxiety,
all of that as a kid that as an adult,
he just looked at it as a problem to be
solved and there's no big deal and it's
another day in the office and I'm just
like,
how fact that you do not fucking
superior see Italy,
how do you manage that?
That's I know.
And you know,
he uh,
fought some of the toughest fighters in
the world without attitude.
I remember one time,
I don't remember who it was he fought,
whether it was Tim Silvia or maybe it
was a,
maybe it was Brendan,
I forget who it was,
but he was on the side of the Octagon
and uh,
I was looking over at him before the
fight started.
He looked over at me and winked.
I'm like,
this guy is so relaxed so you can just
look at you and wink right before he
goes to war.
And he was just so calm about it.
That's one of the reasons why I was able
to keep fighting until later ages.
He was,
he was so common,
they're preserved as energy,
so efficient,
experienced,
you know,
and that Greco Roman man,
he that the ability to control guys.
Apparently everybody says it.
Randy couture was one of the nastiest
guys,
like when he would grab a hold of the
back of your neck,
like that control was so nasty.
You would like.
There's dudes that have like different
levels of control and you really haven't
felt it yet and so you sort of have
like,
a lot of times you view a,
if you train with people that only have
a certain level of skill and then all of
a sudden you train with someone who has
a very high level of skill.
It's baffling to you.
Do you literally aren't even aware that
someone could be so good?
It's staggering to you.
And that was a apparently a lot of
people's assessments of Randy's clinch
that he would get ahold of you.
That's why he was so good at like dirty
boxing guys.
Like when he fought Vito Belfort.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
The first Vito Belfort fight,
especially,
they fought three times,
but the first one,
especially when he beat Vito and Vito
was not just undefeated,
he was just fucking phenol.
He was tearing guys apart in the first
round and and randy stopped him and
randy,
a lot of it was like that dirty boxing
man.
He was so good at it.
Just controlling the back of your head
and and pummeling you with shots and,
and,
and forcing you in the cage and taking
the right angles and know that was a,
that was the birth of random third to
fire fighting.
UFC was like,
how the hell do you go from zero to
fighting Vito Belfort and fucking
animals.
He's an animal and a great guy,
nice guy to be around,
you know,
really nice to just around theater.
And I was really very impressed with
him.
I was like,
man,
these guys are as good as they say.
I'm bad.
There is really a cool guy.
I'm excited that because they asked me
to write a book on his career.
Cool.
I who asks you to do this.
One of the guys that,
these,
um,
enjoy gardener,
he's one of the guys that I know for the
trainers take studying her and so he
said let's work on it together,
you know,
he wanted to do it and then my writing,
so you say helping and we'll write it
and do this thing about Ryan because he
was saying,
you know,
most of the MMA books that are out there
out to biographies,
which are cool.
But then in an autobiography you can
only go,
you know,
you can only hype it up so much because
you sound like an asshole.
Whereas doing it as a third person and
we wheat a lot of the voices from
Houston bone ends kind of like a early
type of thing where you get multiple
feel the,
it's a different way of documentary to
man and that's the plan.
In fact,
to the weight as um,
as a book.
And then to shoot the interviews.
I was there for his very first fight
against Tony Hallmark.
I think it was 1997 or 98.
It might've been [inaudible] 97.
[inaudible] 97.
Thank you.
And uh,
Tony Hama was just giant fucking pro
wrestler and randy couture,
doc under that dude's big punch,
got him,
took him down and strangled his ass.
And I remember thinking,
Holy Shit,
look at that.
Like that was the difference in like one
guy was like his big,
strong sort of progress or type
character.
But the other one had that,
that stupid grappling strength.
They're remembered from some freaks in
high school when I wrestled in high
school,
you know,
when we were in,
um,
you know,
a certain district and I went to the,
the,
I think it was like the regionals and I
forget what it was called,
but you know,
the guys had one,
like certain tournaments would advance
to other tournaments.
And so I got to see like the state
champion wrestlers and I got to see like
some of the really high,
high level wrestlers.
And I'll never forget this,
the way that really good wrestlers could
manipulate guys.
Like just toss them and throw them
around.
I remember thinking Jesus Christ,
like there's like,
just like anything else,
there's guys out there,
they're taking it to a very extreme
level.
Unless you go and see it,
you don't know that that's possible.
So when I first saw randy in the UFC and
he took down that Tony Hallmark,
God,
that's immediately what it reminded me
immediately.
What it reminded me of is the first time
that I'd ever seen real good amateur
wrestlers and went,
Whoa,
like this is.
This is some shit to deal with right
here.
Did you think you had a chance when he
fought the beater,
like because he needed to beat all those
guys?
Were the first guys he beat wearing good
caliber for the ice and then when he
stepped up to five feet or did you?
It was a big leap.
It was his third fighter,
his fourth fight,
third fight.
He did that one night go guys.
And then the next step.
That's incredible.
That really is incredible.
If you stop and think about that.
I,
you know,
I don't think we knew what he was
capable of,
but it was really clear early on that he
was just,
his force of will was just too much.
Randy couture of the most amazing will
ever.
You know,
you look back to the first pedro,
his a fight,
dude,
Pedro,
his hit him with some of the most
horrifying leg kicks that have ever been
landed in an mma fight.
It took him six months to recoup his
legs to rehabilitate his legs.
After that fight,
he showed me,
he still has a hole in his leg.
Muscle died in sport,
the muscle or die.
Think about that.
Pedro Huizar kicks you so hard.
The muscles die for forever in certain
spots on your fucking leg.
So Randy go to her,
gone through that,
and then rehab for six months.
And then they talked him into a rematch.
He didn't want to do the rematch.
He's like,
I don't want to fight this fucking guy.
So they give them a rematch and he beats
them down again.
Yeah,
well,
I think he just knew there's no way I'm
getting leg kick this time.
It just became,
it didn't become a,
you know,
I think when you fight a certain guys,
you start thinking,
oh,
I can take a lead kicker,
and then you fight Pedro Huizar.
You were like,
oh no,
you can't.
No,
Yeah,
that guy,
man.
People don't even know.
One of the reasons why I have such a
fetish for leg kicks,
like people always saying Rogan,
you're so fucking queer for leg kicks.
They art.
It's because I've seen pedro,
his old fight live and I've,
I've seen what's possible.
I know what's possible when Kaiser.
Good man.
I,
yeah,
I definitely call for them too many,
but it's because they're awesome when
they land.
They are not,
they are scary.
Yeah.
So,
um,
if people want to buy your book,
what's the best way to get ahold of it
through [inaudible] dot com or Amazon?
Amazon.
And it is the 50 things.
Was it saying they are not supposed to
know our religion?
And Danielle.
And if someone wants to get ahold of you
on twitter,
what is the uh,
the twitter address?
Oh Shit.
They want to see it's at dba lightly.
If you see a picture of a,
the awful in a baby,
it's DBA Allele b o l e l l I.
thanks for coming on again man.
Always cool talking to you.
We'll have to do it again.
Yeah,
I love it.
I think some other fucked up part of the
history of religion or something to.
Hold on.
Let me,
let me give a shout out to one of your,
uh,
one of your fans or um,
there's this lady,
she's going through a lot of our shade
and so I feel maybe make our day two.
We are a name on the one and only Joe
Rogan podcast.
This lady Angela Morado so are called
human being.
You'll get through it.
Look at you man.
Spreading positive,
positive love and light through the
podcast.
So what is your name again on July?
Morado.
Angela Morado.
Alright,
Angela,
I hope you feel better.
Thanks for tuning in.
Hope you enjoyed this podcast.
Hope everybody enjoyed it.
Thanks to our sponsors.
Go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the link for the
fleshlight.
Entering the code name.
Rogan.
Get 15 percent off.
Number one sex toy for men.
Yay.
I'll get you one.
I know what I'm going to do it tonight.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
and uh,
thank you to [inaudible] Dot com o n n I
t and go to Joe Rogan.net.
Click on the Alpha brain link and enter
entering the code name,
Rogan,
and you will get 10 percent off,
not just the first order to now for any
future orders.
Alright,
we love you guys.
Thanks for tuning in and we will see you
tomorrow.
I'm a WHO's on tomorrow?
Brian?
I don't know.
Hold on a second.
It's,
it's homegrown.
Amy Schumer.
Amy Schumer who've been trying to get
her on for awhile.
She's hilarious.
Chick from the Charlie Sheen rose who
fucking killed it.
Dude.
Some of her lines and she was going back
and forth with Mike Tyson.
I hope we can play some of it.
I don't know if we can,
but either way.
She's hilarious.
So she's on tomorrow.
That's it.
Thanks everybody.
Thanks for tuning in.
Thanks to a tall you find folks out
there in cyberspace and we'll see you in
about 24 hours.
Go by Daniel Bilaterally.